WE'RE LIVE IN AMERICA. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS A
SENTIMENT KEN COOLEY AND I AM
THE CHAIR OF THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY JOINT RULES COMMITTEE.
TODAY THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE
IS CONVENING AN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. RELATED TO THE STATE
CAPITOL ANNEX PROJECT. AND THAT
MEDIAN IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER
AND DULY CONVENED. PLEASE BE
ADVISED OF AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING OF TODAY'S PROCEDURES
BEING MADE. AND IS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED AND THAT WILL BE
AVAILABLE ON THE ASSEMBLY'S
ANNEX PROJECT THIS LITIGIOUS
ENTERPRISE JEFF WEBSITE. ANNEX
DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV.
YOU'LL FIND THAT HEARING THERE
IT'LL BE TELEVISED THE
PRESENTATION WHICH IS GONNA BE
MADE TODAY IS LIKEWISE
AVAILABLE ON THAT WEBSITE.
AGAIN ANNEX DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT GOV. YOU'LL FIND A HEARING
TODAY'S HEARING IN ITS AGENDA
AND PRESENTATIONAL COMBINED
INTO ONE. DO TO GUIDE US ON
PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN CEDAR FOR
THIS HEARING WILL BE LIMITED
FOR THE PRESS AND PUBLIC.
THEREAFTER PHYSICAL DISTANCE
INCLUDED CALLS TO ENTER AND
LEAVE THE CAPITAL AND HERE IN
THE CHAMBER. WE ASKED IF YOU
WERE A MASK- AT ALL TIMES WHILE
IN THE CAPITAL. WHEN WE GET TO
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE AGENDA IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHICH
TO GIVE COMMENTS PLEASE RAISE
YOUR HAND IF YOU WERE IN THIS
CHAMBERS AND YOU WILL BE ASKED
TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
PLEASE DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO GIVE YOUR COMMENTS. YOU CAN
EITHER ACCEPT THE CHAMBER
GALLERY AFTER COMMENTS OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SHORTER OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL. INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USE TO ONLY ONE PERSON
AT A TIME. WE'LL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC. MAY MAKE THEIR COMMENTS
ON THE SUBJECT OF TODAY'S
INFORMATION HEARING ON THE
STATE CAPITOL ANNEX PROJECT.
THE CALL IN NUMBER WHEN WE GET
THAT PORTION OF THE PROGRAM FOR
THE MEETING. IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN. EIGHT SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO FOUR TWO. SIX TWO THREE
SEVEN. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THESE NUMBERS ON THE ANNEX
WEBSITE AT I SAID S. ANNEX ON
ASSEMBLY THAT'S YOU KNOW GO AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU ARE CALL IN ANYWAY PLACE
YOUR CALL AT ANY TIME AFTER
HEARING STARTED. THE OPERATOR
ON THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE SUBJECT MATTER. PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE WHEN YOU CALL
IN. THIS INCLUDES MOVING YOUR
LIFE FOR BROADCAST. ENTER SMART
DEVICE REDUCE SOUND DISTORTION.
IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATE PHONE SERVICE
YOU CAN CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX. THREE ONE NINE
TWO EIGHT ZERO ZERO AND MY
STAFF WILL BE THERE TO ASSIST
YOU. YOU CAN ALSO SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS VIA EMAIL. TO JOINT
DOT RULES AT A. S. SAM. DOT CA
DOT GOV. AGAIN YOU CAN COMMENT
DIRECTLY VIA EMAIL TO JOINT DOT
RULES AT ASM DOT CA DOT GOV.
THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH US
AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ARE
FACING. SO WITH THAT I JUST
WANT TO. HAVING GOT THROUGH
THAT BACKGROUND WHICH IS
RESPONSIVE TO THE ERA IN WHICH
WE FIND OURSELVES WELCOME MY
COLLEAGUES HERE WELCOME ALL THE
PUBLIC WILL BE FOLLOWING THIS
HEARING VIA TELEVISION OR IN
THE GALLERY. I WILL NOTE THAT
TODAY. IS THE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
FOUNDING OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. TODAY'S ADMISSIONS
DAY. SO WE KNOW THE HUNDRED
SEVENTY YEARS AGO THE
CONVERSATION THE STATE WAS ON
THE FUTURE. WHAT IT MIGHT BRING
AND HOW WE WOULD BE. EQUIPPED
TO BEAT THAT FUTURE AND AS WE
MEET TODAY IN THIS ASSEMBLY
CHAMBERS AT THAT IS THE
CONVERSATION- THIS IS A NOT A
NEW CONVERSATION. GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER INITIATED A
COMPREHENSIVE STUDY OF THE
BUILDING BACK IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS. THAT IDENTIFIED MANY
MANY ISSUES WITH THE BUILDING.
UNDER GOVERNOR BROWN UNDER MY
PREDECESSOR OF IT WAS PROPOSED
AND ADOPTED WE SHOULD REBUILD
THE CAPITAL THAT IS TO SAY THE
LEGISLATURE TO REBUILD THE
ANNEX. THAT STATUTE WAS ADOPTED
UNDER MY PREDECESSOR. RULES
CHAIR RECORD IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
AND SO THERE HAS BEEN
CONTINUING WORK OVER THIS TIME
TO BRING FOR SORT OF A
BREAKDOWN OF WHAT THIS PROJECT
MIGHT LOOK LIKE AND I DO WANT
TO SAY TO ANYONE WHO'S
FOLLOWING THIS. R. AS RULES
CHAIR I REGARD MY
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO BRING
SHAPE OF WHAT DECISIONS CAN BE
MADE AND BRING THEM TO THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE AS I SAID
IT THE IDEA TO REPLACE THE
ANNEX OF AN UPDATED STRUCTURE
WELCOMING TO THE PUBLIC.
GETTING RID OF ASBESTOS AND
OTHER SORTS OF THINGS ARE IS A
LONGSTANDING IDEA- APPRECIATE
IN. HE IS CHAIR AND THE CURRENT
GOVERNOR- BUT- TODAY WE BRING
THOSE THINGS TO THE COMMITTEE
SO THE MEMBERS OF THE
DRIVERLESS COMMITTEE LAST EVEN
RECEIVED A PRESENTATION THAT IS
GOING TO BE REVIEWED TODAY AND
IT IS AVAILABLE ON THE WEBSITE-
TODAY. SO PRETTY MUCH THE
MEMBERS OF JOINT RULES AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. RECEIVE
THIS MATERIAL AT THE SAME TIME
SO WITH THAT I THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE- CENTER MARLENE
I INVITE YOU OF MY VICE CHAIR-
FROM MY HOMETOWN AREA OF.
CALIFORNIA TO OFFER SOME
COMMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND IN THE SPIRIT OF
SOCIAL DISTANCING ALL SPEAK
FROM HERE AND- START BY
THANKING YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP PLAN ON THIS IS BEEN
A- LABOR OF LOVE YOU'VE YOU'VE
ATTENDED TO GREAT DETAIL AND
USE STRIVE TO BE INCLUSIVE OF
ALL MEMBERS OF JOINT RULES. THE
LEGISLATURE THE PUBLIC SO I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP. THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF JOINT RULES FOR. WHO
ARE ABLE TO BE HERE TODAY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. THE
GENESIS AND GROWTH OF THIS
ENVISIONING PLANNING. WE'RE
GONNA BE HEARING SOME UPDATES
TODAY BUT WE WILL ALSO LEARN
THAT THE SWING SPACE IS THAT
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT IS ON
SCHEDULE AND MOVING FORWARD- IS
THE CHAIR MENTIONED THIS
THINKING STARTED DURING THE
ADMINISTRATION OF FORMER
GOVERNOR SCHWARZENEGGER
CONTINUED UNDER GOVERNOR
BROWN'S LEADERSHIP AND NOW
UNDER GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
LEADERSHIP. AND WHILE WE FACE
CHALLENGES JUST OF OUR ABILITY
TO MEET AND PARTICIPATE- WE ARE
IN SOME STRICT TIMELINES TO DO
THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS AND I
THINK ONE OF THE TAKEAWAYS
TODAYWILL BE. THE DECISION
MAKING THAT LIES IN FRONT OF US
AND THAT GUIDING THAT IS GOING
TO BE EXPANDED. PARTICIPATION
AND ACCESS AS THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS IS CONDUCTED WITH
PARTICIPATION ALWAYS FOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE'LL
HEAR HOW A LOT OF THESE DESIGN
FEATURES EXPAND TO PROTECT AND
PRESERVE. PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
THERE'S ALSO BEEN A LOT OF
THOUGHT GIVEN TO SECURITY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC TO PROTECT
VISITORS GUESTS STAFF AND
MEMBERS- AND THAT WE WILL HEAR
HAS GONE HAND IN GLOVE WITH THE
DESIGN FEATURES OF INCLUSION.
AND PARTICIPATION AND FINALLY I
THINK WE'LL HEAR SOME UPDATES
TO ABOUT HOW USE OF SPACE WILL
ACTUALLY LEAD TO SOME EXPANDED
PARK SPACE IN. USAGE OF THE
PARK AREAS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
VISITING THE CAPITAL- WEATHERED
SCHOOL GROUPS OR GROUPS HERE TO
VOICE AN OPINION ON ANY
PARTICULAR LEGISLATION SO. WELL
WE FACE THE CHALLENGES RIGHT
NOW THE FIRES BURNING IN OUR
STATE OF THE ON GOING PANDEMIC.
MAYBE THE WORK HERE GIVES US AN
ABILITY TO LOOK FORWARD. TO
PLAN FOR THE FUTURE IN ON THIS
ADMISSION STAY. TO RE COMMIT TO
THE COMMITMENT TO THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY
ARE HONORED AND INCLUDED IN THE
VISION OF MOVING US FORWARD TO
SAFER- TIMELY AND INCLUSIVE
HOUSING FOR THE PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS HERE IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE CAPITOL SO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
HEARING TODAY'S BRIEFING. THANK
YOU MONEY. AT THIS TIME I'D
LIKE TO INTRODUCE OF MISTER
DAVID HART. WITH THE FIRM OF
MOCHA I WILL SAY THAT WAY BACK
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN I WENT TO THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL STATE
LEGISLATORS ASKING THEM IS
THERE SOMEBODY THAT YOU KNOW
THAT HAS WORKED ON CAPITAL FROM
THE COUNTRY. THAT MIGHT HELP US
OUT HERE- IT DIDN'T TAKE THEM
VERY LONG TO GET BACK. TO ME
WITH MISTER DAVID HART. NAME
AND I'VE SINCE LEARNED THAT
PART OF HIS REPUTATION IS THAT
FOUR TIMES. HE HAS HELD VARIOUS
STATES AND UNION REBUILD THEIR
CAPITAL AND BRING IT IN ON TIME
AND ON BUDGET. SO IT'S A-
UNIQUE SKILL SET HE STILL SITS
ON THE ROLE OF OWNER'S
REPRESENTATIVE. SO THAT WE HAVE
SOMEBODY EXPERTS IN THESE TYPES
OF PROJECTS WHO IS STANDING IN
THE PLACE OF THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE. AND PURSUING.
GETTING GUIDANCE OR PROJECT
DECISIONS WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
NEXT HOW TO ADDRESS COST SO
MISTER DAVID HART THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND I. SEE THE FORTY
YOU. THANK YOU. THERE I'M
LEARNING THANK YOU THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE AND IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER TODAY- I THINK WE HAVE
ASSEMBLED- OF THE REALLY GOOD-
AMOUNT OF INFORMATION THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO SHARE
WITH YOU ON BOTH THE VISITOR
CENTER IN THE ANNEX- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT- I THINK IS MOST
IMPORTANT IS THAT YOU RECOGNIZE
THAT WE ARE IN THE- CONCEPTUAL
DESIGN STAGE AND SO THERE'S
STILL A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
WORK TO DO. BUT WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SEE TODAY IS A VERY
GOOD REPRESENTATION OF- THE
DIRECTION THAT THE PROJECT
COULD HEAD AND THAT THE WORK
THAT HAS BEEN DONE IS
REMARKABLE SO WITH THAT WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO DO IS TAKE A
MINUTE TO INTRODUCE THE TEAM
THAT IS GOING TO BE PRESENTING
TO YOU FIRST I'D- LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY COLLEAGUE TELL
YOUR RUCKER SHE'S HIDING BEHIND
THIS MONITORS YOU MIGHT WANT TO
STOP OVER. TELL YOU IS TELL
YOUR IS THE PROJECT COORDINATOR
FOR OUR OFFICE AND SHE'S ALSO
OVERSEEING SOME OF THE
SCHEDULING FOR THE ENTIRE
PROJECT FOR US AND SOCIAL SPEAK
A LITTLE BIT LATER ABOUT THE
SCHEDULE I'D ALSO LIKE TO TURN
SOME TIME OVER TO THE VISITOR
CENTER- TEAM AND CON WITH- MARK
KEVIN ARNOLD'S OFFICE WILL
INTRODUCE HIS TEAM. YOU WANNA
GO AHEAD AND JUST AND IT WAS.
THE. WOOD MARK EVANIER
ASSOCIATES INTO MY LAP IN THE
ALLEY NOW HE REMEMBERS PROJECT
ARCHITECT AND WILL MARK AVENIR
SO SHE HAD. AND JEFF HERE
DEENEY WOULD PLAN CONSTRUCTION-
WHO IS THE LEAFLET FOR OUR TEAM.
K. THANK YOU AND YOU'LL YOU'LL
SEE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE-
VISITOR CENTER AND WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THAT AS WE GO THROUGH THE
PRESENTATION AND I HOPE YOU
FIND THAT INTERESTING. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO INTRODUCE ON MY RIGHT
THE- DESIGN TEAM FOR THE ANNEX-
IT'S MADE UP OF- TWO
ORGANIZATIONS ALL HAVE JOSE
INTRODUCED THE TEAM IF YOU
WOULD. YES YES THEY WERE CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YEAH MY NAME IS A
SAMPLE LOSSES AND DESIGN
DIRECTOR AT THE FIRM OF
SKIDMORE OWINGS AND MERRILL. TO
MY RIGHT HERE'S CHLOE LOVES. AN
ASSOCIATE THAT TIME AND-
FURTHER DOWN IS- GRANT
REFUNDING ANYTHING EXECUTIVE
WITH TURNER CONSTRUCTION
COMPANY. THAT'S GREAT. SO I'M
GOING TO TURN SOMETIME OVER TO
JOSE TO TAKE YOU THROUGH A
LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY. WE WILL
THEN TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
HOW THE PROJECT HAS KIND OF
COME ABOUT. WE WILL THEN HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE VISITOR
CENTER THEN WILL MOVE INTO THE
ANNEX. AND THEN WE'LL WRAP IT
UP AND TURN IT BACK OVER FOR
SOME QUESTIONS SO JOSE. LET
YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON AND ON
BEHALF OF- BOTH THE COVER THEIR
OLD PLANT TEAM OF PHILADELPHIA
FIND MATT TURNER TEAM- LIKE I
HAVE TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO YOU
TODAY- WHAT- THE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN HAPPENING THE LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS. IF YOU KNOW WILL BE
TALKING OUT ABOUT WHAT
PROJECTS- THE VISITOR CENTER
HERE THE NOTED IN THE ORANGE.
RIGHT IN FRONT OF THE CAPITOL.
AND THAT AT THE REQUEST A
PHEONIX REPLACEMENT WHICH YOU
SEE HERE AND- WE ARE A LOT OF
CAPITAL TO THE EAST DAVID- SORT
OF MENTION A LITTLE BIT OF OUR
AGENDA WHAT WE'RE GONNA TOUCH A
LITTLE BIT ON THE- PROJECT
NICKENS IN HISTORY. THEN WILL-
ADDRESS SOME OF THE- PRINCIPLES
THAT WERE SET UP BY THE PROJECT
OVERVIEW THINK WITH REPORT. AND
I WILL ALSO ALK ABOUT FROM
FIVE TEN CONSIDERATIONS AND
OPPORTUNITIES BEFORE WE GET
INTO A DETAILED PRESENTATION.
OF THE OF THE VISITOR CENTER IN
THE CAPITAL AND THEN. THEY
WOULD WILL CLOSE IT UP WITH
SOME UPDATES ON BUDGET AND
SCHEDULE SO WITH THAT. LIKE TO
START WITH THAT LITTLE BIT OF
THAT HISTORY AS ALL YOU DAHLE
AT ABOUT THE CAPITAL PARK- SITS
IN THE- CENTER OF SACRAMENTO.
AND YOU CAN SEE A THREE NATION
SHIP OF THE CITY CORRECT. AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY HOW THE AXES
OF AXES THAT THIS BUILDING SETS
UP. IN HOW IMPORTANT THAT
RELATIONSHIP. IS TO THE REST OF
THE CITY THE WEST AXIS BEING
MORNING THAN THAT NOT ONLY SETS
THE FRONT OF THE BUILDING BUT
ALSO FITS. THAT DOOR AT IS
SYMBOLICALLY THE FRONT DOOR OF.
THE CALIFORNIA- SEAT OF
GOVERNMENT. SO THESE A VERY
VERY IMPORTANT AB FROM
URBANISTIC ARCHITECTURAL.
LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY THIS IS
THE IMAGES OF- OF IT BUT
CAPITAL IN ITS HISTORIC SETTING
THE VERY BEGINNING OF IT
HUNDRED AND KNOWLEDGE SEVENTY
YEAR EXISTENCE I BELIEVE- IN
THE LATE EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
SEVENTIES FIFTY SHADES- RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE PARK. THAT
AND IT'S DOME IS SLIGHTLY
TILTED TOWARDS THE WEST TO MARK
THE END OF THE WEST CORD IT
EXPANSION AS WELL AS TO FAVOR.
THE MORE IMPORTANT SIDE WHICH
IS THE FRONT DOOR ON THE WEST
SIDE. AND THEN TO THE LEFT
THERE YOU SEE AN OVAL- THAT
USED TO BE A YAK CARRIAGEWAY.
THAT ALSO REINFORCES THAT AXES
ANYTHING WHITE SAID THERE WAS
ALSO AN APPROACH. TO THE
BUILDING FROM THE EAST SIDE. A
LITTLE BIT OF HIS HERE AND YOU
KNOW AS YOU KNOW AS THE
BUILDING HAS INVOLVED THE
NEEDED FROM. AS WE GO ALONG TO
BE ABLE TO ADAPT TO. THE NEEDS
OF THE TIME YOU CAN SEE HERE
HOW TO CARRY TAXES. MOVE WAS
REPLACED BY THE AUTOMOBILE
ACTORS AND THEN. LATER ON IN
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO THE PROCESS
GOT LARGER AS THE POPULATION OF
CALIFORNIA. EXPANDED ANOTHER
HERE. AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
TURN OF THE NINETEENTH CENTURY
NINETEEN FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
FOUR. YOU CAN SEE HOW THE
MATURE TREES THAT WERE
RESPONDING TO THE ORIGINAL
GEOMETRY OF THE OF THE PARK. I
FRAMING THOSE VIEWS TO THE
DOME. AS WELL AS THE PILOT WAS-
THAT EXISTED NOT TODAY A LITTLE
BIT FURTHER IMPORTS- USED TO BE
MARKING THAT THRESHOLD- TENTH
STREET THINK CREATING AN ENTRY
TO THE PARK. AND THEN LASTLY
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AND OF
THE CAPITALAND X. IN NINETEEN
FIFTY TWO. WITH NOTABLY AT THE
INTRODUCTION OF PARTICULAR
RAMPS TO ACCESS THAT BELOW
GRADE PARKING. IN THIS IS AN
IMAGE OF THE CAPITAL OF THE
CITY TODAY- THIS IMAGE ALONE.
IT PRESENTS- THAT. I THINK THAT
HOW HOW SIGNIFICANT AND
IMPORTANT THIS PROJECT IT AND
OBVIOUSLY IT TELLS ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO RESPECT THIS
BILL. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE LEARNED THROUGH THE
SPENDING A LITTLE BIT OF THE
HISTORY OF THIS BUILDING IF
THAT SETTING IS THAT MANY
THINGS HAVE HAD TO CHANGE TO
ADAPT TO THE TIMES AND THAT THE
IMPORTANT THING ST DOOR. AND
THAT WE THINK THAT. THE BEST
THING THAT WE CAN DO TO FOR
THAT CONTINUED INTO INDOOR. IS
TO ACTUALLY. RESERVE A BUILDING
THAT IS FULLY FUNCTIONAL. AND
EFFICIENT AS THE CALIFORNIA
CITY GOVERNMENT. SO VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE TRANS FAT WE
THINK. REGARDING THE ONYX-
THERE WAS A REPORT AND I THINK
OF MR COOLEY THE GERMAN COOLEY
RISK- REFER TO THIS THE FINAL
REPORT OF DECEMBER TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. WHICH THE CALL OUT
FOR A FEW DEFICIENCIES BY THE
ONYX BECAUSE THAT THAT ARE IN
NEED OF AFTER. AND THEY THEY
RANGE FROM LIKE FIFTY TO
ACCESSIBILITY. IN OVERCROWDING
AS YOU CAN SEE YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE CIRCULATION PATHS ARE VERY
CROWDED AT TIMES. AND THEN ALSO
FROM THE WORK SPACE PERSPECTIVE
THERE ARE MANY SHORTCOMINGS FOR
THE SHORTCOMINGS BEING
DEFICIENCY BUT MEETING SPACE-
OUTDATED TECHNOLOGY. AND
FAILING INFRASTRUCTURE SO MANY
THINGS THAT ARE ARE ARE
PERHAPS- NOT WORKING SO WELL IN
THE EXISTING ON. CONSEQUENTLY
THE L. THE COMMITTEE YES. SHOW
UP I NEED TO BE ABLE TO READ.
HI CONSEQUENTLY- THE- PROJECT
OVERVIEW IN SEQUENCE REPORT
WAS- I ADOPTED TO NOT ADDRESS
TWENTY NINETEEN AND THIS IS A
THIS REPORT. I CAN YOU HEAR ME
NOW YEAH. YEAH THIS REPORTS- A
STATES THIS PRINCIPLES I'M MORE
ALONG. OTHER USEFUL DESIGN
GUIDELINES THAT WILL. INFORM AT
THE DESIGN TEAM ON HOW TO
PROCEED AND WITH THE PROJECT.
SO THE VERY FIRST OF THOSE
PRINCIPLES IS TO BE INCLUSIVE
AND WELCOME OBVIOUSLY I WAS
CALIFORNIA AS A BECAUSE OF THE
PEOPLE IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
THAT IT BE INCLUSIVE AND. AND
WELCOMING THAT'D BE INVITING.
THAT'D BE TRANSPARENT IN THOSE
OF ARCHITECTS SAY IT REQUIRES
THAT THE BUILDING BE VERYPOOR.
AND NOTHING BETTER. TO START
THAT FEROCITY THAT WITH THE
FRONT DOOR AS WELL AS
MAINTAINING- THREE OTHER
ENTRIES ON THE NORTH SOUTH AND
EAST. THE VISITOR CENTER
PERHAPS ENTRANCE IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT ONE BECAUSE THAT
RESTORES THE HISTORICAL AND
CURRENT. NEXT WILL BE THE
ENTRANCE WILL HAVE SOME
INTERESTING BILLS THAT WOULD BE
EQUIPPED WITH THE LATEST IN THE
SECURITY PROCESSES. AS WELL AS
IN TECHNOLOGY TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE VISITORS THE MEATS AND
ALSO OBVIOUSLY AFFECT YOU. AND
THAT IT WILL BE FULLY
ACCESSIBLE THROUGHOUT BOTH
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE. AS WE
ACCESS THE BUILDING. THERE'S A
NEED. TO RELIEVE THAT
OVERCROWDING IN WE THINK THAT
THAT THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS A FEW COMMENTS INTO THE
BUILDING IS TO HAVE A AMPLE-
PUBLIC A SPACE THAT WILL BE
ABLE TO BE SAFE- THAT THAT THAT
CAN I BELIEVE THAT OVERCROWDING
AND PEOPLE WHO WILL BE ABLE TO
ACCESS. AND THAT WILL BE.
COMFORTABLE AND DIGNIFIED AND
OBVIOUSLY IT ALSO- PEOPLE CAN
FEEL PRIDE OFTEN THIS IS THIS
IS THAT IT IMAGES OF VERY
CONCEPTUAL IMAGES OF WHAT THAT
THE SPACE MICHAEL TALK ABOUT.
ONE IN THE VISITOR CENTER AND
THE OTHER IN THE ONYX IN WILL
BE ABLE TO REFER BACK TO THE-
TO THE TO THE- DAHLE. ANOTHER
OF THE PRINCIPLE THIS TO BE ONE
BUILDING AND THAT REFERS BACK
AS HAVING THE ABILITY TO
CONNECT- BOTH THE HISTORIC
BUILDING. AND THE AND THE AND
THE NEW ANNEX AND NOTHING
BETTER TO DO THAT THAN A LINING
THE FLOORS SPECIFICALLY. TO BE
ABLE TO GO BACK AND FORTH
SEEMINGLY THEME AND TO BE ABLE
TO MAKE SURE. THAT IT ALL
FUNCTIONS AS ONE BUILDING. AND
THEN IT DOESN'T PRINCIPLE THE
CALL IT'S CALLED EDUCATION SEE
TO EVERYTHING WHICH HE RELATES
TO THE- TO FACILITATING A
PRODUCTIVE- PRODUCTIVE WORK DAY
AND ALL OF YOU THAT LIVE IN
THIS BUILDING KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO BE CLOSE TO
EVERYTHING. AND THIS IS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT WE TAKE- FROM
THE EXISTING ONYX THAT. WE
THINK THAT IT WORKS WELL AS A
DAY BECAUSE THIS CONTINUOUS
CIRCULATION NO DEAD ENDS.
FIGURE EIGHT CIRCULATION THAT
ALLOWS YOU TO MOVE IN THE U.
YOUR TO GO TO WHERE YOU NEED TO
BE FILLED. WOULD LIKE TO BRING
THAT. INTO THE NEW NEW DESIGN
AND BE ABLE TO CONNECT AND ON
CONTINUOUS FLOW. AND THEN BE
FUNCTIONAL AND OBVIOUSLY ALL
FLOORS NEED TO BE FUNCTIONAL
BUT THIS FLOOR THE SECOND FLOOR
WERE SPENDING RIGHT NOW IS
CRITICAL IN TERMS IT'S NOT
WISHING THE CONNECTIONS OF THE
ASSEMBLY TO THE REST OF THE
FLOOR. AS WELL AS THIS THE SET
THE ENTRY LEVEL FLOOR WE CALL
THIS LEVEL. THE GARDEN LEVEL
THIS IS SLIGHTLY BELOW THE- THE
FIRST LEVEL OF THE ROTUNDA. BUT
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE
AS THEY COME IN AND HAVE A VERY
GOOD WAY FINDING- WAIT TO GET
INTO THE BUILDING. SO WITH THAT
I LIKE TO. PASS IT ON TO MY
COLLEAGUE- CHLOE LOGS THAT THEY
WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THE SITE
IN SOME OF THE. THANK YOU JOSE.
SO THE CAPITOL BUILDING IS
DESIGNED TO SET SLIGHTLY
ELEVATED ABOUT THE POCK AND
THIS IS BOTH TO PROTECT IT FROM
FLOODING BUT ALSO TO GIVE IT
ITS CIVIC PRESENCE AND THAT'S
CIVIC PRESENCE IS FURTHER
ENHANCED BY THE GEOMETRY OF THE
POCK WHEREVER YOU'RE STANDING
THE PODS DIRECTING POINTS OF
VIEWS TOWARDS THE CAPITAL TO.
AND ALTHOUGH TODAY THOSE POTS
AND JAVA TREES HAVE CHANGED
SLIGHTLY. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESERVE AND ENHANCE THOSE
VIEWS ARE VERY MUCH STILL
PRESENT. ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY IS
TO REINFORCE THE HISTORICALLY
THE HISTORICAL PROMINENCE OF
THE AXES AND ESPECIALLY THE
WEST IT'S AXES. BY REINSTATING
AND REINFORCING THE WEST ENTRY
WHICH TODAY IS AND USE. AS WELL
AS REINFORCING THE EAST ENTRY.
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY AND READY
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION IS THIS
IDEA THAT THE CAPITAL IS A
BUILDING WITHIN A POCK AND THIS
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO THE
DESIGN TEAM AND MAXIMIZING IN
HAN SAYING AND PROTECTING THE
PARK IS ONE OF UTMOST
PRIORITIES. RIGHT NOW THE
EXISTING THE EXISTING RAMPS
DOWN TO THE PARKING READY
BIFURCATE THE POCK AND IMPEDE A
FREE AND EASY FLOW OF
CIRCULATION FOR PEDESTRIANS.
HOWEVER WE SEE A READY GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO RELOCATE THOSE
RAMPS. AND THEREFORE COMPLETELY
RECONNECT THE POCK READY
ALLOWING. PEDESTRIANS TO SAFELY
ONE THE POP CONNECTING THE SIDE
OF THE CAPITOL GROUNDS TO THE
EAST SIDE OF THE POT. WHICH WE
THINK IS A TREMENDOUS BENEFIT
TO THE PROJECT. AND BECAUSE THE
CAPITAL IS- SLIGHTLY ELEVATED
FROM ITS NEIGHBORING STREETS
THIS NEW POP CONNECTION REALLY
HELPS US FACILITATE TRUE
UNIVERSAL ACCESS THROUGHOUT THE
SITES AS WELL AS INTO THE
BUILDING. ANOTHER IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION OF THE TREATIES.
SO THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
DEDICATED IN LARGE TREES AROUND
THE SITE. AND AS YOU CAN SEE A
HANDFUL OF DEDICATED SMALL
TREES WILL BE IMPACTED BY THE
ANNEX BUT CAN BE EASILY
RELOCATED. THE REMAINDER OF THE
TREES ON THE SOUTH AND THE
NORTH AND NOT IMPACTED AT ALL
BY THE FOOTPRINT OF THE ANNEX
AND WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT A BIT
LATER. HOWEVER THE FOOTPRINT OF
THE PARKING WAS A BIT MORE
CHALLENGING FOR THE DESIGN TEAM
AND WE LOOKED AT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT OPTIONS. WE LOOKED AT
LOCATING IT ON THE SOUTH SIDE.
AS WELL AS ON THE NORTH SIDE
AND AS YOU CAN SEE BOTH
LOCATIONS IMPACT THE TREES
QUITE SEVERELY. AS WELL AS BOTH
OF THEM REQUIRING A SECOND
MEANS OF EGRESS WHICH WOULD
MEAN FURTHER IMPACTING THE POP
AND TUNNELLING UNDERNEATH THE
BUILDING. AND SO THE DESIGN
TEAM SAID ON A ON A LOCATION TO
THE EAST WEAVING THE PARKING-
BELOW THIS PAUL STREET RIGHT OF
WAY AND READY HAVING THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF IMPACT ON THE TREES.
AND HOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT A
BASEMENT PLAN UP THE PARKING.
YOU CAN SEE HOW WE'VE LOCATED
THE RAMPS TO THE PREFERRED TO
THE PERMIT UP IN THE NORTH AND
THE SOUTH AGAIN READY
MAXIMIZING PEDESTRIAN SAFETY
WITHIN THE POP. AND WE HAVE
READY TIA TWO ENTRIES FROM AND
THEN L. STREET. AS WELL AS A
TWO MEANS OF EGRESS BOTH OF
WHICH COULD BE EASILY REVERSED
OF THE CITY STREETS CHANGE. AND
ANOTHER GREAT PET BENEFITS OF
LOCATING THE PARKING AT IS THAT
THE LEAD OF THE PARKING CAN
BECOME A READY GREAT PEDESTRIAN
PROMENADE THAT CONNECTS. ALLEN
N. STREET ANY SENSUALLY
CONNECTS A PEDESTRIAN
EXPERIENCE TO THE LARGEST CITY
GRID. AND SO HAVING THIS READY
VIABLE WEST ENTRY YOU CAN
CONNECTING- VISITORS THROUGH
CAPITOL MALL STRAIGHT INTO THE
VISITOR CENTER ON THE WEEK. ON
THE WEST ALONG WITH THE ENTRY
ON THE EAST READY REINFORCES
THAT HISTORICAL AXES THE
WESTIES AXES. AND BECAUSE WE
ALREADY MAKING A TRULY
ACCESSIBLE CONTINUE WITH POP-
ENTRY TO THE GROUNDS IS
ACCEPTABLE FROM ALL OF US FOR
EXAMPLE FROM THE CAPITOL
PARKING ON THE NORTH AS WELL AS
THE AYE LOBBY ON THE SOUTH.
WE'RE ALSO ALLOWING FOR TO A
GROUPS AND SCHOOL BUSES TO BE
ABLE TO TALK DIRECTLY ON TENTH
STREET AND EASILY AND SAFELY
FIND THEIR WAY INTO THE VISITOR
CENTER FROM THE WEST. AND IF
FOR ANY REASON THE VISITOR
CENTER IS DELAYED. THESE SCHOOL
BUSES ENTER GROUPS WILL BE ABLE
TO POP IN FIFTEEN THREE TO MAKE
THEIR WAY THROUGH CAPITOL PARK
AND INTO THE BUILDING ON THE
EAST. AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
HAND IT OVER TO A COLLEAGUES
AND FRIENDS THAT MIGHT HAVE
BEEN THEIR ARCHITECT. ON KENYAN
ATTY ORMERECE.
THANK YOU
CLOSELY. MY NAME IS KHAN KEYON
WITH KEVIN AIR ASSOCIATES
COLLEEN ALLEY TO DO BEFORE.
WILL BE TAKING YOU GUYS THROUGH
THE VISITS SAID THE PROJECT- WE
HEAR ON BEHALF OF PLAN. PLAN
CONSTRUCTION CATHARINE PICK
KEVIN HERE TEAM. SO THIS IS A
SITE PLAN SHOWING THE VISITOR
CENTER WHICH IS IN THE MIDDLE.
TO THE LEFT OF THE WEST WING
BUILDING. AND WHAT ONE WANTED
TO AGAIN POINT NOW IS THE ONLY
INDICATION OF THE AXIS- NORTH
SOUTHEAST WEST. IN THE BUSINESS
CENTER IS LOCATED DIRECTLY. ON
THE EAST WEST AXIS CONNECTING
W. QUARTER TO THE CAPITOL MALL.
AND BECAUSE THE TONE SHIFTED
WESTWARD TRADITIONALLY THE
PUBLIC ENTRANCE ON THE WEST
SIDE. THE BUSINESS CENTER AND
NATURALLY WILL SERVE AS A NEW
PUBLIC ENTRANCE- AND AGAIN FROM
THE WEST SIDE. WELL WE WANT TO
ALSO POINT OUT IS. BECAUSE WE
ARE PUTTING THE BUSINESS CENTER
BELOW GRADE. WE ARE REALLY
RETAINING THE IMPORTANT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE THREE
BUILDINGS ON THE SITE ACROSS
TRENTON STREET THE ON
REBUILDING THE MOSQUE BUILDING.
THOSE WITH BILL- MEANT TO
COMPLEMENT THE CAPITOL BUILDING
SO WE RETAINING THAT IMPORTANT.
RELATIONSHIP. AND BY BY ADDING
A DROP OFF ZONE ON TENTH STREET
FOR SCHOOL BUSES- VISITORS- THE
NEW DROP OFF AREA REALLY ALLOW
IT YOU I THINK FOR ME FOR THE
FIRST TIME. TO REALLY MAKE A
STRONG CONNECTION TO THE
MONUMENTS ACROSS TENTH STREET.
SO YOU HAVE- YOU HAVE A COUPLE
MONUMENT YOU GOT THE FOUNTAIN
AND THEN WE WILL BE REPLACING
RELOCATING BACK- THE- COMMAND
CAMON CAMON COMMEMORATIVE
SEALS- THAT'S ON THE PLAZA
RIGHT NOW IN ITS CURRENT
LOCATION. SO THE EXISTING PLAZA
IT'S ABOUT TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED SQUARE FEET. AND
THE NEW PLAZA WHICH IS ACTUALLY
IN TWO PIECES THE OF THE OPERA
PLAZA IN AS A LOCALIZA IT'S
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET SO SLIGHTLY LARGER.
AND WHAT IT'S ALLOWING US TO
DO. IS RETAINING THE STRONG
RELATIONSHIP TO THE CAPITOL
MALL BUT ENHANCING THE
CIRCULATION OF THE AND THE
SAFER WAY TO CROSS TEN STREET-
BECAUSE WE'RE CREATING A BOLD
OUT. MAKING THE CROSSING EASIER
CREATING A DROP. SAFE FOR BUSES
AND SCHOOL CHURN AND WE
ENHANCING THE CIRCULATION
WITHIN THE PARK- WITH TWO
DIFFERENT PLAZA- THERE'S
DEDICATED ENTRANCE SPACE INTO
THE BUSINESS CENTER IN THE WEST
WING. AND ALLOWING. STILL THE
ACTIVITIES THAT MIGHT OCCUR ON
PLAZA EVENTS GATHERING
PROTESTS- WITHOUT. IMPEDING ON
THE PROPERTY. SO THIS IS
PERSPECTIVE. OF THE- THE NEW
VISITORS CENTER YOU CAN SEE
THAT. THE CAPITOL BUILDING-
WHAT JOSE TALKED ABOUT BEFORE
THE TREES THE GROUNDS AND THE
PROMINENCE IN THE DOME NONE OF
THAT IS IMPEDED. IN A VIEW FROM
CAPITOL MALL- SHOWING THE DROP
OFF ZONE HOW IT'S PROTECTED AND
SECURE- WOULD POLITICS AND FOR
THE VERY FIRST TIME THIS ALLOW
FOR ACCESSIBLE ENTRANCE INTO
THE WEST WING- FROM THE WEST
PORTAL WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND WE TOOK A GREAT
CARE TO PROTECT AND PRESERVE
THE MATURE CEDAR TREES TO THE
LEFT TO RIGHT. AND AS YOU GET
CLOSER YOU CAN SEE THAT WE
HAVE- INTENDS TO BRING BACK THE
PILLARS OF THE MONUMENTS TO THE
ORIGINAL HISTORICAL CATIONS
MARKING THE ENTRANCE. INTO THE
PUBLIC- ENTRANCE INTO THE
EXHIBIT SPACE. SEVEN AS YOU GET
CLOSER- YOU CAN SEE LEGEND
SHIPPING UP APPLAUSE AND A
LITTLE PLAZA- IN. THERE IS A
NOW A OVERHANG SPACE FOR
QUEUING THERE SO YOU'RE
PROTECTED FROM THE ELEMENTS.
THE ENTRANCE THE DESIGNED TO BE
VERY TRANSPARENT VERY
WELCOMING- WE REALLY WANT YOU
TO FEEL LIKE THIS IS THE SPACE
YOU WANT TO BE. SO NOW WE'RE
MOVING INTO THE FLOOR PLAN. SO
TO THE LEFT IS THE BUSINESS
CENTER MIDDLE. EAST THE
EXISTING WEST WING CAPITOL
BUILDING AND THEN TO THE. LEFT
TO RIGHT IS THE ANNEX. SO THE
END INCOMING OF THE PROGRAM THE
PROGRAM IS REALLY INTENT
INTENDED TO ALLEVIATE A LOT OF
THE ISSUE THAT'S BEEN MENTIONED
IN THE BLUE BOOK- CONGESTIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE DEFICIENCIES AND
A HOST OF THE ISSUES SO. THIS
WHOLE PLAN IS SHOWING IS IN THE
MIDDLE THERE'S A VERY LARGE
SECURITY QUEUING SPACE AND THEN
AFTER THAT THERE IS A GATHERING
SPACE RECOMPOSE SPACE FOR YOU
TO GET ORGANIZED SO FOR TOUR
GROUPS- THIS MAY BE A ROUTE
THAT YOU WOULD YOU WOULD CHOOSE
TO DO TO EXPERIENCE THE
BUILDING SAYS YOU COME IN
THROUGH SECURITY YOU MAY TURN
LEFT NORTH OF UPPER SIDE OF THE
BUILDING AND WHERE THE
ORIENTATION ROOMS OR- OR YOU
MAY CHOOSE TO GO DOWN WHICH IS
THE BOTTOM. OF A CELL- TO VISIT
EXHIBIT SPACE- OR IF YOU COME
IN THE BUS GROUP UP THE LONG
LONG BUS RIDE YOU MAY WANT TO
GO TO THE RESTROOMS WHICH IS
LOCATED IN THE UPPER LEFT HAND
CORNER FOR VISITORS. WHO JUST
WANT TO GO INTO THE WEST WING
ON THE ANNEX DIRECTLY. THEY CAN
PROCEED. PRETTY IN A PRETTY
STRAIGHT FORWARD MANNER UP THE
STAIRS INTO THE LOWER TANDA.
AND ANGLE OF ELEVATORS OR
STAIRS INTO THE WEST WING OR
CONTINUE ON INTO THE ANNEX
BUILDING. THERE'S AN ACCESSIBLE
PATH OF TRAVEL AS WELL. SO WE
ARE CONTEMPLATING THE BUILD OUT
OF BUSINESS CENTER IN TWO
PHASES THEIR FIRST RACE WHAT WE
CALL KORN SHELL. WHICH IS THE
ENTIRE FOOTPRINT OF THE
BUILDING AND THAT WOULD ALSO
INCLUDE SECURITY QUEUING.
GATHERING SPACE. S. ROOMS AND
ALL THE MECHANICALS FACES AND
ALSO WILL NEED TO DO SOME WORK
ON THE WEST WING SORRY IN ORDER
TO MAKE CONNECTION BETWEEN THE
VISITORS CENTER AND THE WEST
WING BUILDING. FOR FACE TO
WHICH IS PRIMARILY TENANT
IMPROVEMENT WOULD BE EXHIBIT AN
ASSOCIATE SPACES- AS WELL AS
THE ORIENTATION GROUPS. SO AT
THIS POINT I'M GOING TO HAND
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE NATALIE.
GOOD AFTERNOON. WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE IS A SECTION
CUT THROUGH THE SITE STARTING
WITH TEN STRAIGHT ON MY LEFT A
SLOPING WALKWAY BRINGS YOU DOWN%
TO THE VISITOR CENTER BELOW UP
IN INTO THE WEST WING. AND
THROUGH TO THE ANNEX. HERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT HAVE YOU TAKEN
WITHIN THE QUEUING AREA.
LOOKING PAST SECURITY AND
THROUGH TO THE WEST WING. A
LARGE OVERHEAD SKYLIGHT BRINGS
DOWN NATURAL DAYLIGHT INTO THE
SPACE AS WELL AS PROVIDES
DIRECT VIEWS TO THE STARK THE
SIDE OF THE WEST WING ABOVE.
THIS CONNECTION IS FURTHER
REINFORCED THE ARTICULATION OF
THE OPENINGS OF THE PARTICLE
ABOVE BEING BROUGHT DOWN TO
THIS VISITOR CENTER LEVEL. FROM
THE SPACE THERE'S ALSO VIEWS
INTO THAT EXHIBIT SPACE WHICH
IS ENVISIONED TO HAVE CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT CONTACT. THIS VIEW
OF THE EXHIBITS AS WELL AS THE
WEST WING BEING AT THE
FOREFRONT OF THE VISITOR ENTRY
REALLY SEEKS TO CREATE A SENSE
OF EXCITEMENT AND ANTICIPATION
AS WELL AS CLEAR WAYFINDING.
HERE'S A VIEW LOOKING FROM THAT
SAME SPACE BUT NOW UP IN
TOWARDS THE DOME. THIS ICONIC
VIEW OF THE HISTORIC FACADE
REALLY IS INTEGRAL TO YOUR
SENSE OF ARRIVAL. AND ENTRY
INTO THE CAPITAL. THIS IS A
VIEW TAKEN FROM THE EXHIBITS
ENTRY. LOOKING TO EXHIBIT SO
THE RIGHT AND THE GATHERING
SPACE ON THE LEFT AND THE WEST
WING TO THE FRONT. YOU'LL
NOTICE HOW OPEN INCLUDE THE
SPACES ARE TO ONE ANOTHER. AS
YOU ENTER THE VISITOR CENTER.
THE VIEW INTO THE EXHIBIT SPACE
WILL PROVIDE VISUAL INTEREST
AND EXCITEMENT. THE REALLY
EXCITING TO ALL VISITORS TO
REALLY ENCOURAGE THEM TO
EXPLORE ENGAGE WITH THE CONTENT
WITHIN THAT SPACE. THIS IS A
VIEW OF THE GETTING SPACES WELL
WE'RE NOW ON THE OTHER SIDE. OF
THAT SPACE LOOKING TOWARDS THE
WEST WING. SO THE GATHERING
SPACES THE SPACE IMMEDIATELY
AFTER SECURITY SO AFTER WE GOT
THROUGH SECURITY. IF YOU WANT
TO GROUP WITH THE GROUP YOU CAN
CONTRAVENE THE CENTER NEEDED TO
THE RESTROOMS THOSE ARE KIND OF
BEHIND US IN THIS VIEW WORKING
TO THE ORIENTATION ROOMS. YOU
WANT HEAD STRAIGHT INTO THE
WEST WING YOU MAY. GIVE ME A
MOMENT TO GATHER YOUR THOUGHTS
ARE THINGS YOU CAN HEAD TO THE
LONG WINTER BENCH. LATER KICK
INTO THE EXHIBITS OR YOU CAN
ALSO CONGREGATE IN FRONT OF THE
LARGE DIGITAL. WALL TO THE LEFT
THE SPACE. THIS IS A VIEW- WERE
NOW ON THE PATHWAY LEADING UP
INTO THE WEST WING BUT NOW
LOOKING BACK TOWARDS A VISITOR
CENTER AND TRADE. FROM HERE YOU
HAVE DIRECT VIEWS INTO
ADDICTIVE SPACE YOU HAVE USE
INTO THE MAIN ENTRY. OUT TO THE
CALIFORNIA PLAZA. BEYOND AS
WELL AS THE CAPITOL MALL. AND
THEN TO THE RIGHT HE HAD VIEWS
OF THAT DIGITAL WALL. THIS
FINAL VIEW IS ACTUALLY TAKEN
FROM THE BASEMENT OF THE WEST
WING WE'RE NOW ON THE LOWER
RETURNED THE AREA LOOKING BACK
OUT TOWARDS THE VISITOR CENTER.
ENTRANCE BECAUSE HE DIRECT
CONNECTION BETWEEN INDOOR AND
OUTDOOR AND THE STRONG VISUAL
AND PHYSICAL CONNECTIVITY
REALLY REINFORCES THE NOTION OF
ONE BUILDING. LET'S NOT I'M
GONNA TURN IT BACK OVER TO
DAVID PART.
WITH. THANK YOU
WE'RE GOING TO SPEND A MINUTE
NOW AND TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE IMPACTS OF THE VISITOR
CENTER ON THE CAPITAL OR THE-
THE ANNEX AND- WHAT IF IT'S
BUILT AND WHAT IF IT'S- NOT
BUILT. SO THE FIRST THING I
THINK TO UNDERSTAND IS THAT THE
LOGIC BEHIND THE- THE VISITOR
CENTER IS IT A D. CONFLICTS
THE- CONGESTION THAT IS
CURRENTLY TAKING PLACE TODAY
WITHIN THE CURRENT ANNEX AS YOU
KNOW TODAY- ALL OF THE VISITORS
AS WELL AS- MEMBERS AND
EVERYBODY WHO'S WORKING HERE
COMES THROUGH THE TWO PRIMARY
DOORS NORTH AND SOUTH AND
THERE'S A NEW STORE- WHAT THIS
DOES IS IT CREATES PITCH POINTS
AND IT CREATES CONFLICT- WITHIN
THOSE MAJOR CORRIDORS. BY
HAVING THE WEST ENTRY WE CAN
TAKE THOSE- SCHOOL GROUPS TOUR
GROUPS AND VISITORS AND HAVE
THEM COME IN- GATHER AND GET
READY FOR THEIR TOUR USE THE
RESTROOMS AND THEN AND ORGAN
MANNER TAKE THE TOUR AND GO
THROUGH THAT WITHOUT CREATING A
LOT OF CONGESTION FOR MEMBERS
AND THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE
WORKING ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS
SO IT IMPROVES THE CIRCULATION-
BY PULLED TOGETHER AND ALLOWING
FOR THE GROUPS TO ASSEMBLE AND
THEIR LOGICAL LOCATIONS IT
IMPROVED LEARNING BE IT ALLOWS
FOR US TO DEVELOP EXHIBITS AND
UNDERSTANDING ABOUT CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRACY. WITHIN THE VISITOR
CENTER TO WHERE THEY CAN TAKE
THE TIME AND THEY CAN LEARN
ABOUT THAT RATHER THAN STANDING
IN THE HALLWAY IS LOOKING AT
THE CURRENT EXHIBITS AND
CONTESTING THAT AND IT IMPROVES
THE OVERALL FUNCTION. OF THE
ANNEX BY SEPARATING THESE TWO
FUNCTIONS INTO THEIR
APPROPRIATE LOCATIONS IT ALLOWS
FOR THE- FUNCTIONAL ASPECTS AND
THE SQUARE FOOTAGE THAT'S BEING
BUILT IN THE ANNEX BEING USED.
TO HELP- FURTHER THOSE
ACTIVITIES AND IT ALLOWS FOR
THE LEARNING CURRENTLY WE HAVE
BROKEN THE VISITOR CENTER INTO
TWO DISCRETE PHASES AS KONG
MENTIONED. PHASE ONE IS WHERE
WE BUILD THE SHELL OF THE
BUILDING WE BUILD THE ENTRY
PORTIONS WHERE THE SECURITY AS
WE BUILD THE GATHERING PLACES.
AND WE BUILD THE RESTROOMS WE
BUILD THE CONNECTION TO THE-
WEST WING- THE POS BUDGET AS-
ADDENDA FIDE IN THE DOCUMENT
WAS THIRTY TWO POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. WE ARE
CURRENTLY AT ABOUT FORTY POINT
EIGHT AND- THAT PROJECT HAS
BEEN PUT ON HOLD WE BELIEVE
THAT IF THIS PROJECT WAS TO
MOVE FORWARD WE COULD FIND WAYS
TO CONTINUE TO REFINE THAT. WE
ARE CURRENTLY IN IN WHAT'S
CALLED THE CONCEPTUAL PHASE
WHICH MEANING IS WERE RIGHT AT
THE VERY BEGINNING WE STILL
HAVE SCHEMATIC DESIGN AND
DESIGN DEVELOPMENT CONSTRUCTION
DOCUMENTS TO GO THROUGH. AND AS
WE GET MORE INTO THE PROJECT
AND WE LEARN MORE WE BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE ABLE WILL BE ABLE
TO TIGHTEN THAT BUDGET UP.
PHASE TWO. IS REALLY THE
EXHIBIT PHASE IN THIS IS NOT
BEEN FUNDED- AS YOU YOU MAY OR
MAY NOT KNOW THE- EXHIBITS WERE
NOT PART OF THE APPROPRIATION
AND SO THAT NEEDS TO STILL BE
FUNDED. ONCE THE EXHIBITS ARE
DETERMINED THEN WE CAN
DETERMINE WHAT KIND OF BUILD
OUT WHAT KIND OF. FINISHES WE
NEED WITHIN THE ORIENTATIONS
ROOMS AND WITHIN THE EXHIBIT
SPACE. OUR EXPECTATION AT THIS
POINT RIGHT NOW IS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE EXHIBIT
PHASE. AND THAT WOULD HAVE TO
BE A NEW APPROPRIATIONS SO
CURRENTLY THE IMPLICATIONS OF
HAVING THE VISITOR CENTER ON
HOLD WHICH IS WHERE IT
CURRENTLY IS. IS THAT IT
REQUIRES US TO INCREASE CERTAIN
CIRCULATION ACTIVITIES WITHIN
THE- THE WE WILL NEED
ADDITIONAL SPACE WITHIN THE
SECURITY AREAS SO THAT WE CAN
HANDLE THE VOLUME OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE COMING IN. RATHER THAN
JUST HAVING THEM COME IN WITH
THE NORMAL TRAFFIC SO THAT'LL
INCREASE. IN SOME AREAS ONE TO
TWO MAGNETOMETERS- WE ALSO NEED
ADDITIONAL RESTROOMS TO BE
PLACED- WHICH WILL CHEW UP A
LITTLE BIT OF THE- FUNCTIONAL
SPACE THAT'LL HAPPEN BOTH ON
THE- GARDEN LEVEL AND ON THE
FIRST FLOOR. AND THEN- THE
BIGGEST IMPACT IS REALLY THE
CIRCULATION SPACE BECAUSE WE
NEED TO ACCOMMODATE
APPROXIMATELY. A MILLION
VISITORS A YEAR AND I WILL TELL
YOU THAT ONCE THIS IS DONE. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
IN THE FOR CAPITALS THAT WE
HAVE DONE IS THE SPIKE OF
VISITORS GOES THROUGH THE ROOF-
IN UTAH WE SOUGHT TRIPLE. IN
MINNESOTA WE SOUGHT DOUBLE IN
IN WYOMING THEY SET RECORDS-
FOR VISITORS- IN FACT WHEN WE
OPEN TO WYOMING STATE CAPITOL
THEY HAD PEOPLE. ALL THE WAY
OUT ONTO THE LAWN AND DOWN THE
STREET- THE LARGEST CROWD SAID
THEY'D EVER SEEN SO. YOU WILL
HAVE AN INCREASE IN VISITOR
TRAFFIC SO THAT ONE MILLION
VISITORS IS LIKELY TO GO UP.
NOW WHETHER IT DOUBLES IT OR
NOT I CAN'T SAY BUT- WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WE ACCOMMODATE THE
CIRCULATION CAPABILITIES WITH
WITHIN THE BUILDING. THEREFORE
WE HAVE. HAD TO ADD
APPROXIMATELY YOUR USE
APPROXIMATELY FIVE THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED SQUARE FEET. OR
IT'S COSTING US ABOUT SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. OF THAT FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANYWAY TO-
UTILIZE OUR TO PREPARE THE
ANNEX TO RECEIVE. THOSE
VISITORS. NOW WE HAVE DONE SOME
STUDIES WITH REGARDS TO HOW
THAT LAYS OUT SO ON THE LEFT
YOU CAN SEE. IN THESE NEXT
DIAGRAMS THE LAY OUT OF WHAT WE
CALL THE DOUBLE T. AND WILL
ALSO GO THROUGH THE CIRCLE IN
THIS WHERE. BUT THAT'S THE
SPACE THAT WE WOULD NEED TO
ALLOCATE. IF THERE WAS. NO
VISITOR CENTER IF WE BUILD THE
VISITOR CENTER. THEN IN THE
NEXTAG GRAHAM TO THE RIGHT YOU
CAN SEE THAT IN THE RED AREA WE
ARE ABLE TO REDUCE THAT SQUARE
FOOTAGE. AND VIRTUALLY SAVE
THOSE DOLLARS FROM HAVING TO
BUILD THAT. THE BLUE AREA IS
SQUARE FOOTAGE THAT WE'RE ABLE
TO REPURPOSE AND PUT BACK INTO
THE FUNCTIONAL ASPECTS. TO WEAR
BOTH ON THE GARDEN LEVEL WHICH
IS WHERE THE HEARING ROOMS ARE
AND ON THE FIRST FLOOR WHICH IS
WHERE THE EXECUTIVE SUITES ARE.
THEY WILL THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
USE THAT FOR OFFICE FUNCTIONS
OR FOR HEARING OR FUNCTIONS.
AND SO YOU CAN SEE THAT IN ALL
THREE OF THESE IT'S
APPROXIMATELY THE SAME ABOUT.
ELEVEN TO TWELVE HUNDRED SQUARE
FEET COULD BE ELIMINATED
THEREBY SAVING US SOME MONEY.
AND APPROXIMATELY FOUR THOUSAND
SQUARE FEET CAN BE REPURPOSED.
AND SO IN THE DOUBLE T. YOU SAW
THAT IN THE CIRCLE YOU CAN SEE
WHERE WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
REGAIN SOME OF THE- FUNCTIONAL
SPACE. AND IN THE SQUARE YOU'LL
SEE THAT NOW YOU'LL SEE MORE OF
THESE DESIGNS IN A FEW MINUTES
WHEN JOSE PRESENTS THOSE. IN
SUMMARY WHAT THAT REALLY SAYS
IS THAT WE CAN SAVE BETWEEN.
TWO POINTS ONE POINT TWO
MILLION AND ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN SAVINGS. AND
WE ARE ABLE TO REPURPOSE
BETWEEN THREE POINT OR FOUR
POINT SIX. FOUR FOUR THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED SQUARE FEET. TO
FOURTH- TWO THREE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED SQUARE FEET SO IT'S A-
IT'S A GOOD BENEFIT TO BE ABLE
TO USE THOSE SPACES IN A IN A
DIFFERENT WAY. SO AS YOU SIT
AND CONSIDER THIS TODAY WE
RECOGNIZE WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM BUT WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE YOUR DIRECTION- IN THE
NEAR FUTURE WITH REGARDS TO
WHETHER YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THIS CONTIUE OR WHETHER YOU'D
LIKE TO SEE A STAY ON HOLD. AND
WITH THAT I WILL. TURN THE TIME
OVER TO JOSE. WHO WILL TAKE US
THROUGH THE DISCUSSION ON THE
ANNEX.
SO. I HEARD PLOY AND I
WILL BE TAKING YOU THROUGH THE
WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN- PUTTING
TOGETHER FOR THE CAPITAL THE
CAPITAL AND X. THE TEAM HAS
PREPARED THAT- THREE
ALTERNATIVE FOR YOU TO CONSIDER
THIS CONCEPT TO CALL THE DOUBLE
T. CIRCLE IN THE SQUARE. AND
WE'RE GONNA PRESENT ADMIN- AND-
IN THIS SORT OF FORMAT THE ALL
THREE TOGETHER BECAUSE AS THEY
RESPOND TO THE PRINCIPLES AND
GUIDELINES SET UP BY THE P. O.
S. AS WELL AS THEY ALL HAVE THE
SAME PROGRAMMATIC- ELEMENTS.
THEY'RE VERY SIMILAR- HOWEVER.
THEY ALSO AVE SOME- DIFFERENT
ATTRIBUTES FOR THE WILL LIKE TO
POINT OUT TO YOU. SO THE THREE
IMAGES THE BOTTOM- YOU KNOW
POINT OUT HOW. THE THAT
PNEUMATIC SORT OF SITS IS TO
THE WEST SIDE OF THE OF THE
WEST WING AND NESTLED IN
BETWEEN THE TREES. AND THAT IT
IS- YOU KNOW- RESPECTFUL OF THE
HISTORIC BUILDING. ALL THREE OF
THE SCHEMES ALLOW FOR THAT TACK
CRITICAL PRODUCTION CONNECTION
THAT KHLOE MENTIONED AND WE
THINK THIS IS A GREAT BENEFIT.
TO THE PROJECT INTO THE PARK.
SO ALL THREE DO THAT THEY ALSO.
HAVE MAINTAIN THOSE VIEWS TO
THAT TO THAT DAHLE MAY NEED
SOME CASES- MAYBE ENHANCE IT A
LITTLE BIT. YES. VERY. THE
LITTLE BLACK HOURS. AND OTHER
THE PALM TREE SORRY THE
RESOLUTION ON THE SCREEN IS NOW.
YEAH YEAH YES. YEAH WHERE ARE
SHOWING THE- AT RIGHT LOCATION
OF ALL THE TREES THAT CAREFULLY
SURVEYED THAT FILL ALL THE
TREES ARE YOU SEE IN OUR IMAGES
ARE IN THE RIGHT LOCATION AT
THE RIGHT TIME. ALL OF THE
SCHEME IS ALSO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO REVEAL- A PORTION OF THE
WEST WING FACADE THAT NOW IS
COVERED BY BY THE ONYX- SO WE
THINK THAT IS ALSO A BENEFIT-
THAT THAT NEW PROJECT WILL
BRING. ALL THREE SCHEMES OF
THREE CONCEPTS- ALSO STATE WAY
BELOW THE AT WHAT WE CALL THE
ONE TWENTY FIVE FOOT LINE WHICH
IS MARKING THE BOTTOM. OF THE
COLONNADE OF THAT ON THE DOME
SO NOT NON OF THE BUILDING
ELEMENTS WOULD GO TO ALL BE
GOING ABOVE THAT. ALL THREE
SCHEMES ALSO ARE RELATING TO
THE SIGNIFICANT FEATURES OF THE
WEST WING MAINLY THE CORNERS
AND THE TOP OF THE BOTTLE
STRAIGHT. THEY ALSO REVEAL A
BIT BACK YOU CAN SEE THERE IN
THE PLAN- FROM THE WEST WING TO
SET IT UP OPPOSITE MORE
IMPORTANT TYPE OF BUILDING
THERE FOR. OUR PHRASE THAT WE
USE THAT THIS CALL THAT THE
WEST WING NEEDS TO BE FIRST
AMONG EQUALS. AND IT OBVIOUSLY
WORKED VERY CAREFULLY WITH THE
SURROUNDING TREES BECAUSE THEY
ARE PART OF THE OVERALL
COMPOSITION. AND THEY HELP US
SET UP THE WEST WING ALSO AS
THE MOST IMPORTANT- BUILDING AT
ON THE FIVE. ALL THREE SCHEMES-
CAPITALIZE ON ON ACCESS TO
DAYLIGHT IMPUSO WHO OBVIOUSLY
OF ALL THE SPACES THAT ARE
ABOVE GROUND THERE'S A MAJOR
DIFFERENCE THOUGH BETWEEN THE
DOUBLE T. AND THE CIRCLE IN THE
SQUARE IN THAT THAT DOUBLE T.
IS LOOKING OUTWARDS MOST OF THE
STATE WITH THE WORK SPACES AT
LOOKING OUTWARDS. WHEREAS IN
THE CIRCLE AND IN THE SQUARE AT%
BOTH- INWARDS AND OUTWARDS
VIEWS WILL BE PROVIDED. YOU CAN
SEE THERE ON THE LEFT HAND SIDE
A NEW WORD FOR YOU THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO LOOK INTO THIS
COURTYARD AND HAVE USED TO THE
TO THE DAHLE. AND THEN THE ODD
WORD BE WITH WILL BE OBVIOUSLY
TO THE PARK AND THE THREE. ALL
THE THREE SCHEMES- HAVE ADOPTED
THE CNCEPT THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT EARLIER THAT IS BROUGHT
ABOUT FROM FROM THE EXISTING
IONIC SIX THAT ARE. THE HEAD
CONTINUOUS CIRCULATION. AND ALL
THE OBVIOUSLY THAT IS BROUGHT
IN INTO THE CHAMBERS AND OTHER
ELEMENTS OF THE WEST WING AS
WELL. VERTICALLY ALL THREE
SCHEMES WILL HAVE- THREE GROUPS
OF ELEVATOR I MEAN FOR GROUPS
OF ELEVATORS THAT WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED WRONG ARE ALONG THE
FLOORS-TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
ALL FLOORS. AND THAT'S WHERE
ALL THE ENTRYWAYS CONVERGE AT
THE NEXUS OF IT WILL HAVE. ALSO
A PUBLIC STAIRWAY- THAT WILL
CONNECT BOTH ALL THE FLOORS OF
THE WEST WING IN ALL THE
FLOORS. ON THE NEW IPHONE X.
THIS IS SPACE THAT WE'RE USING
TO PUT THE STAIRWAY IS-
REMINISCENT OF- THE OLD APPS
THAT WITH STAKING OUT WHEN THE
NINETEEN FIFTY TO ANNEX WITH
IN. SO WE'RE TAKING A LITTLE
BIT OF THAT HISTORY INTO THE
NEW PROJECT. AND THEN HEAR SOME
VIEWS OF WHAT THAT IS THERE
MIGHT LOOK LIKE- OBVIOUSLY WILL
LIKE TO PUT FROM ACCESS TO
DAYLIGHT AT THE TOP AND HAVE
THE ABILITY TO. RECALL THE
DOME. IF YOU WALK UP THE STAIRS
THERE'S A SPARE WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT AND FOR VISITORS TO
BE ABLE TO CONNECT FROM THE
ENTRY LEVEL WHAT WE CALL THE
GARDEN LEVEL. UP TO THE ROTUNDA
LEVELING EVEN TO THE SECOND
LEVEL AND THEN OTHER USERS IN
THE IT AND THE STAFF AND
VISITORS WILL BE ABLE TO DO
THIS. USE THE SPARE. FOR
CIRCULATION BETWEEN FLOORS. WE
TALKED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
FLOOR ALIGNMENTS ALL THREE
SCHEMES ARE DOING JUST THAT IT.
HOWEVER WE'VE- I DID A
MEZZANINE RIGHT ON TOP OF THE
SECOND FLOOR BECAUSE WE WERE
BUILDING QUITE A BIT OF VOLUME-
BECAUSE OF THE ALIGNMENT. OF
THE OF THE OF THE FLOORS TO THE
KING TO THE WEST WING WE WERE
ALREADY HAVING THAT ABILITY TO
INSERT A MEZZANINE THERE TO
CAPITALIZE ON THE EFFICIENCY OF
THE VOLUME THAT WE'RE BUILDING.
PROGRAMMATIC LEE- ALL OF THE
WORK SPACE ESPECIALLY THE
MEMBER SWEETS AND ALL OF
SUPPORT THE SPACES WILL BE
LOCATED FROM THE SECOND FLOOR
UP WITH OBVIOUSLY VERY
IMPORTANT AT CONNECTION TO
CHAMBERS ON THE SECOND FLOOR.
THE EXECUTIVE FLOOR WILL BE
ASSIST NOW IN THE FIRST FLOOR.
ALL THREE OF THEM HAVE BEEN
THERE. AND THEN THESE NEWLY
DEVELOPED FLOOR THAT WE CALL
THE GARDEN LEVEL THAT HAS
ACCESS. TO TWELVE THREE RIGHT
AWAY YOU MIGHT REMEMBER CHLOE
TOLD US THAT THIS BUILDING IS A
SLIGHTLY- PERCHED UP ABOVE THE
SURROUNDING STREETS SO THAT
FACILITATES. AN ENTRY RIGHT-
BELOW THE FIRST LEVEL AT IT
WHICH IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
PUT ALL OF THE HIGHLY ACCESS-
THE SPACES THAT NEED YOU HAVE A
LOT OF ACCESS FROM THE PUBLIC
PERSPECTIVE WHICH ARE THE HERE
ROOMS FOR ALL THE KIßM
HEARING RIVER LOCATED IN THIS
FLOOR. AND THAT GIVES US ALSO
AN ADVANTAGE FROM A LIFE SAFETY
PERSPECTIVE IN THAT WE CAN EXIT
A STRAIGHT OUT. ONTO THE TO THE
SIDEWALK. AND THEN LASTLY THE
BASEMENT BASEMENT THAT HOUSES-
SOME- COMMITTEE ROOMS AS WELL
AS OTHER SUPPORT SPACES. AND
ALSO PROVIDES- AT- AN ENTRY
FROM THE PARKING INTO THE
BUILDING. WE TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT PUBLIC FACING
THE PORTENTS OF THIS PUBLIC
SPACE YOU CAN SEE HERE- SOME OF
THE IMAGES BELOW WHAT THAT.
MIGHT LOOK LIKE THEY'RE HOWEVER
SOME DIFFERENCES THE DOUBLE T.
IS A NARROW AND- VERY TALL
ATRIUM SPACE WHERE THE PUBLIC
WILL BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE OF
THE SPACE AND AT EVERY LEVEL.
IN OTHER WORDS THE PUBLIC WILL
BE ABLE TO. BE LOOKING DOWN
INTO THE SPACE YOU KNOW ALL THE
WAY FROM THE TOP OR OR AT ANY
LEVEL THAT ONE. THERE AT THAT
WHEREAS THE CIRCLE AND A DOUBLE
P. AS MORE OF A BROADER TYPE OF
SPACE MORE ABOUT A CALL IN THE
PUBLIC ROOM. BUT IT ALSO ONLY
CONNECTS- THAT CARD LEVEL IN
THE FIRST LEVEL SO IT'S A TWO
STORY. INSTEAD OF- ALL THE WAY
UP. EIGHT THE VIEW A LITTLE BIT
SO BECAUSE THIS IS A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE SCHEME. HERE'S A DOUBLE T.
AND- IN THAT IN THAT. IMAGE IT
THERE TOO TO THE RIGHT THERE'S
A PRECEDENT IMAGE. OF A ONE OF
A PROJECTS THAT WE'VE DONE WITH
A SIMILAR TYPE OF THE SPACE YOU
CAN SEE HOW. THE CIRCULATION
AND IS BARCLAYS WILL BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THAT A SPACE AT EVERY LEVEL.
AND THEN HERE'S WHAT THAT MIGHT
LOOK LIKE IN THE CIRCLE- IS
ONLY A TWO STORY SPACE
CONNECTING THE GARDEN LEVEL
AGAIN WITH THE WITH THE
EXECUTIVE FLOOR. SO IT'S MORE
OF A GALLERY TYPE SPACE PERHAPS
COULD BE USED FOR SOME EXHIBIT
SPACE. AND THEN IT'D BE CAPPED
WITH WHAT WE CALL A LADY LIKE
TO YOU KNOW BASICALLY A
SKYLIGHT THAT IS LOWER. THAN
THE TOP OF THE BUILDING. ALL
THE UPER FLOORS WILL BE A
LITTLE MORE INDEPENDENTLY SAY
FROM THIS PUBLIC SPACE DONE.
AND DONE THE DOUBLE PHD.
LIKEWISE THE SQUARE IS- IT
ARRANGES SIMILAR NATURE JUST
THE JAVA TREES DIFFERENT. WITH
THAT I LIKE TO CALL BACK- CHLOE
TO GO THROUGH SOME ENTRY
SEQUENCE.
SO YEAH WE'RE LOOKING
AT A CROSS SECTION OF THE
DOUBLE T. AND WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE YOU THROUGH AN ENTRY
SEQUENCE OF ALL THREE SCHEMES
STARTING WITH THE DOUBLE T. SO
YOU CAN SEE AS YOU ARRIVE ON
THE EAST YOU'RE GREETED WITH
VERY VISIBLE VIEWS OF THE DOME.
AND THIS IS BOTH FOR AWAY
FINDING TOOL BUT ALSO FOR HIS
STARK REVERENCE THROUGHOUT THE
BUILDING. THIS IS A VIEW JUST
OFF THE SECURITY AS YOU'RE
ABOUT TO APPROACH THE PUBLIC
SPACE. AND HERE IS THE PUBLIC
SPACE YOU CAN SEE THIS AMPLE
DAY LIVES. THIS FRAME VIEWS TO
THE DOME AND- THAT'S WHAT THEY
MENTIONED. THE SPACE IS
ACTIVATED ALL THE WAY UP SO
THIS. TRULY BECOMES THE
PEOPLE'S HOUSE. AND THEN THIS
IS A VIEW FROM ONE LEVEL UP.
THIS IS- THE ENTRY TO THE
GOVERNOR'S SUITE. SO YOU CAN
SEE IS READY GRAN SPACE LOOKING
DOWN ON TO THE PUBLIC SPACE
LOOKING UP TO THE DOME AND
LOOKING DIRECTLY AHEAD IN FRONT
OF YOU YOU CAN SEE. THE VIEW
STRAIGHT INTO THE WEST WING.
AND THEN SIMILARLY WITH THE
CIRCLE. AS YOU APPROACH THE
CIRCLE YOU SEE GLIMPSES OF THAT
DOME. AND THEN THIS IS A VIEW
STRAIGHT OFF TO THE SECURITY
YOUR LEADS THROUGH A CORRIDOR
INTO THAT SECULAR PUBLIC SPACE.
IN THIS WE THINK COULD BE A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY A FLEXIBLE
SPACE PERHAPS FULL- TEMPORARY
OLE PERMANENT EXHIBITS FOR
GALLERY FULL FULL MOTIFS I'M-
AND THEN THIS IS THE VIEW
FALLOUT FROM THE LEVELUP AGAIN
FROM THE GOVERNOR SPACE LOOKING
BACK DOWN ONTO THAT. ROUND FACE
AND LOOKING STRAIGHT THROUGH
INTO THE WEST WING. AND THEN
AGAIN VERY SIMILAR TO THE
CIRCLE YOU SEE THE SQUARE THE
APPROACH FROM THE EAST. AS
YOU'RE COMING OUT FROM SECURITY
AND YOU'RE LED INTO THE PUBLIC
SPACE WITH VIEWS UP TO THE
DOME. AND AGAIN A FLOOR UP ON
THE FIRST FLOOR FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S ENTRY. AND I'M GONNA
GIVE IT BACK TO JOSE AND I'M
GOING TO. WELL JOSE'S TALKING
I'M GOING TO COME DOWN TO THE
MODEL AND SPEND THE MODEL A
LITTLE. MMHM. THIRTY TWO- PLAY
MUSICAL CHAIRS MIGHT WE THOUGHT
THAT IS SPEAKING THROUGH A
MASK- MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT
THAT THAT DIFFICULT BECAUSE SO-
WILL HAVE I'M I'M GONNA TAKE
OVER NOW IN THAT BAG WALK YOU
THROUGH- GOING COUNTER TOP
THROUGH THE SITE AND- CHLOE
WILL BE SPINNING THE MODEL KIND
OF TRYING TO ORIENT YOU IF YOU
CAN SEE IT. AND THERE SO HERE'S
THE FIRST FEW. WE'RE LOOKING-
FROM THE SOUTHWESTAPPLE TO THE
CAPITOL BUILDING AND YOU CAN
SEE THAT- BOTH THAT DOUBLE T.
IN THE CIRCLES TO RECEIVE BACK
A LITTLE BIT TO IN AND BEHIND
THE CAPITAL MAKING IT. A LITTLE
BIT MORE PROMINENT WEARS A
SQUARE IS MORE OF A FLASH
CONDITION IN A LET IT ALIGNING
WITH THAT WITH THAT SOUTH AND
NORTH. FOR FIVE. IT IS A BIT
MORE- THEY SAY- IN PARALLEL
WITH THE CAPITAL. THIS IS A
VIEW NOT LOOKING IS STRAIGHT-
ISTA ON THE NEWLY. THE NEW- SO
PEDESTRIAN WALKWAY THAT WILL BE
RECONNECTING- THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS WITH THE PARK. A IN
HERE YOU CAN SEE ALSO THAT THAT
RESET RECEIVE THAT THAT. THAT
THE DOUBLE T. FOR EXAMPLE
RECEIVED BACK THERE IN THE
MIDDLE A LITTLE BIT TO ALLOW
THE CAPITAL TO BE MORE
PROMINENT AND JUST AS
IMPORTANTLY GIVING US- TREES ON
THE SOUTH AND MAINLY THE NORTH
OPEN THE MOON TREE AND SO FORTH
A LITTLE BIT MORE ROOM. AT WHAT
THAT DOES IS IT. MAKES THE EAST
SIDE OF THAT BUILDING TO
PROTRUDE A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
SAY THAT THE LIMITS OF THE OF
THE NORTH AND SOUTH OF SOUTH OF
THE CAPITAL. THE CIRCLES A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT IN THAT
IT'S GEOMETRY IS VERY COMPACT
AND- WELL WE SEE IT FROM- FROM
FROM ABOVE AS IT LOOKS LIKE A
VERY BIG BUILDING BUT WHEN YOU
ARE AT EYE LEVEL. THE GEOMETRY
OF THE CIRCLE ALWAYS IS BY
GOING AWAY FROM YOU SO YOU
NEVER REALLY SEE THE ENTIRE
VOLUME OUT OF THE BUILDING
BECAUSE ALWAYS PEELING AWAY
FROM YOU. SO THAT ALLOWS
NATURALLY BY GEOMETRY BE ABLE
TO PULL AWAY FROM. FROM THAT
FROM THE HISTORIC STRUCTURE IN
AND CREATE THE ROOM- FOR THE
TREES AS WELL. THE DOUBLE THAT
THE SQUARE IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT IN THAT YOU KNOW IT
OUTLINES WITH THAT NORTH AND
SOUTH FACADE FOR THE OF THE-
WEST WING. A. N. YOU KNOW
FEMALE MORE PROMINENT- FACADE-
YOU KNOW I AM COMPETING A
LITTLE BIT MORE WITH THE WEST
WING BUT STILL. ABLE TO BE
RESOLVED IN A IN A IN A GOOD
WAY. FOR THE TREES AND MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT OF MORE CHALLENGING
TO DEAL WITH THE MILITARY BUT
WE THINK- THAT WE CAN. WE CAN
STILL PRESENT A TREE. AND THEN
ALL THREE OF THE FACADES ALSO
REVEALED BACK THE- THE HISTORIC
FACADE OF THE SITE OF THE WEST
WING. AND THIS IS A VIEW A
LITTLE FURTHER EAST- FROM THE
SOUTHEAST LOOKING BACK AT THE
DOME AND YOU CAN SEE HOW. THAT
THE BUILDING THREE FEEDBACK- A
BIT ALLOW YOU TO STILL HAVE A
VERY GOOD VIEW TO THE DAHLE.
AND THAT IS WITH THE TREES SO
THE TREES ARE SOLD DANCE AROUND
THE SITE THAT YOU KNOW ALL OF
THESE VIEWS ARE OBVIOUSLY. FROM
PICKING FROM AWAITING THE TREES
THE TREES ARE VERY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THE OF THE CONTEXT OF
ALL OF THIS PROJECT SO WE MUST
THAT BE BE REALLY REALLY.
CAREFUL ABOUT HOW WE DEAL WITH
A- THIS IS A VIEW GOING UP-
THE- TWELVE STREET FROM ANOTHER
THAT. LOOKING OVER. WELL.
SOMETHING. RIGHT. THERE IS.
SOMEWHERE THE CORRECT. HELLO
YEP NOT SMELL MUCH BETTER SO AS
I WAS SAYING THIS VIEW IS
LOOKING NORTH- I'VE- THAT TOLD
THE STREET RIGHT AWAY- ONE OF
THE DIFFERENCES IS THE CIRCLE-
IT PROTRUDES A LITTLE BIT OUT
INTO THIS RIGHT AT AREA YEAH
CREATING A PORCH- AN ENTRYWAY.
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY THE DOUBLE
T. IN THE SQUARE WILL NEED TO
RELY ON A SMALLER CANOPY OR
SMALLER GESTURES TO BE ABLE TO-
THE NOTE THAT THAT ENTRY WAY
AND THAT'S WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
WITH THE TREES SO THAT THE
BUILDING IS FAIRLY WELL THE
SCREEN WITH A LOT OF THE TREE.
ANOTHER OF USES- LOOKING. AND
WE'VE ALL OF THE SCHEMES HAVE A
WHAT WE CALL AN INCISION OR A
GESTURE TO BE ABLE TO FRAME-
THE VIEW TO THE TO THE DAHLE.
AND THEN DENOTE AN IMPORTANT.
ONTO ON TO THE NEXT BUILDING.
HOWEVER IF WE LOOK FROM THE
VANTAGE POINT WHERE WE THIS
PERSPECTIVES WERE TAKEN THE
TREES ARE SO DENSE THAT YOU CAN
BARELY SEE IT. I'M SURE THAT AS
YOU WALK THROUGH THE PARK THERE
REMAIN INSTANCES THAT YOU CAN
SEE THROUGH THE TREES AND STILL
BE ABLE TO SEE THAT THEY'LL-
AND THEN LASTLY- THE VIEW-
LOOKING AT- FROM THE- I GUESS
IS THE NORTHEAST. AT THE MOON
TREATS YOU CAN SEE IT THERE.
HOW THE DOUBLE T. AND YOU CAN
SEE IN THE PLANT THERE ON TOP-
THE RED THE RED LITTLE CIRCLE
THAT IS THE MOON TREE THAT IS
THE DREAM THAT. THE COMES THE
CLOSEST TO THE STRUCTURE-
DOUBLE T. AND THIS IN THE
CIRCLE ARE ABLE TO- STAY AWAY
FROM THAT TREE AND ABLE TO
PRESERVE REQUIRED QUITE A BIT.
WE THINK THAT THE SQUARE STOLE-
ABLE TO DO THAT B. AS IT AS IT
IS IT WILL BE. ALMOST IN THE
SAME LOCATION AS THE EXISTING
ANNEXES BUT IT WE NEED TO HAVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE STUDY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT TREE COULD BE
PREPARED. WITH THAT SCHEME. AND
THEN HERE'S A VIEW- WITH ALL
THE TREES TOGETHER SO- YEAH WE
ARE MAKING EVERY EFFORT TO TRY
TO PRESERVE THE TREES OF MANY
OF THEM. THAT WE CAN. FROM A
PERFORMANCE PERSPECTIVE- THIS
CAPITAL WILL PROBABLY BE ONE OF
A- HIGHEST ENERGY. PERFORMANCE
OF ANY CAPITAL IN THE NATION.
AND WE ALSO OF FOCUS A LITTLE
BIT ON THAT ASPECT OF WELLNESS
AND THE TOO TOP ROWS THERE ARE
ABOUT THE LIGHT AND GLARE WHICH
IS YOU KNOW. MANIFESTA SILVA
HOW THE INHABITANTS IN THERE
WILL BE ABLE TO HAVE ACCESS TO
THE DAYLIGHT IN AND BE ABLE TO
DEAL WITH CARE THEREFORE AS THE
THOUGHT OF THE LOWER- I WROTE
THERE IS ABOUT- SOLAR RADIATION.
AND I THINK THAT THE CIRCLE
PERFORMS A LITTLE BIT BETTER
THAN THE OTHERS. EVEN THOUGH
THEY ALL A LOT HAVE A GOOD
PERFORMANCE. LASTLY WE HAVE-
WORKED THE PROGRAM IN ALL THREE
OF THESE CONCEPTS. IN ITS
TOTALITY FROM ON ALL THE FLOORS
AND WE THINK THAT THEY ARE
WORKING WELL AND THEY HAVE A-
GOOD FUNCTION FUNCTIONALITY AND
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE SPACE
AND WE WILL BE WORKING TOGETHER
WITH THE AUTHORIZED
REPRESENTATIVES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SPACES ARE FUNCTIONING
FOR THAT. FOR YOU FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS FOR THE
EXECUTIVE. BRANCH HERE'S A
CIRCLE. FAMOUS LAY OUT. AND
THEN THE SQUARE. AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE WE'VE- FOUND
MANY COMMONALITIES AND WE SORT
OF GROUP THEM HERE- FOR YOUR
READING AND ALL THAT SOME OF
YOU HAVE- THE PACKET OR HALF
MAY HAVE RECEIVED THE PACKAGE
YESTERDAY. AND WE'VE SORT OF A
GROUP THEM IN TWO CATEGORIES
THE WORK WORKDAY PRODUCTIVITY
WELL BEING AND THAT OF A PUBLIC
AND USER SUCH AS SAFETY AND
ACCESSIBILITY AND THEY ALL WE
THINK OUR GREAT IMPROVEMENT-
FROM FOR MORE SITTING HERE
TODAY ON. THE ALEX. WITHOUT
THAT WE BUY ONE FOCUS ON THE
MODEL AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT.
FOUR THOSE VIEWERS THAT ARE ON
THE INTERNET YOU MAY WANT TO
FOCUS THE CAMERA ON THE MODEL
NOW AND- YEAH IF WE COULD GET
THE TELEVISION ON THE MODEL AND
WHOEVER'S IN THE ROOM CAN CA.
SO WE LIKE TO USE THIS AS A
TOOL JUST TO REITERATE SOME OF
THE POINTS THAT WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THAT THE THREE DIFFERENT
SCHEMES. SO YOU CAN SEE YEAH
THE DOUBLE T. HOW IT CINCHES IN
IN THE MIDDLE READY TO CREATE
READING ROOM FOR THE WEST WING.
AS WELL AS TO PROTECT AND
PRESERVE THE THREE FIVE ON THE
NORTH AND THE SOUTH. AND THEN
YOU SEE HOW I'M THE REST OF
THAT SQUARE FOOTAGE IS PUT IN
THE BACK. AGAIN IN A PLACE WITH
NO EXISTING TREES. AND YOU CAN
ALSO SEE HOW THE RHYTHM OF THE
DOUBLE T. THE FACADE RHYTHM
READY FAST. YOU LAKE THAT
RHYTHM. ON THE WEST WING. AND
I'M GOING TO VERY CAREFULLY
TAKE THIS ONE OUT. IT WAS. AND
THEN WE CAN PUT THE CIRCLE AND.
AND I'VE BEEN DOING THAT YOU
CAN SEE. WITH THE SEVERAL PM
JUST BY VIRTUE OF ITS GEOMETRY.
THAT THE GEOMETRY NATURALIST
INCHES IN AROUND THE WEST WING.
GIVING THE WEST BRING A LOT OF
BREATHING ROOM AS WELL AS
TENSIONS IN TO THE EAST- AND WE
MENTIONED HOW THE CIRCLE RATES
THIS PORCH OVER THE TWELFTH
STREET RIGHT OF WAY READY
CREATING A KIA ENTRANCE INTO
THE BUILDING. ANOTHER WE
LOOKING AT THE MODEL NOW FROM
ABOVE. IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THIS AS A PEDESTRIAN FROM MY
LEVEL THE GEOMETRY READY IS
ALWAYS RECEDING AWAY FROM YOU
SO YOU NEVER QUITE EXPERIENCED.
THE FULL THE FULL- THE VOLUME
OF THE OF THE SCHEME. WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE THE FUN OUT. YOU
HAVE THAT. THEN WILL AND WITH
THE SWIFT GAME. THE DEFINITELY
THE DRAMA THREE OF THE WAY
POSSIBLY GEOMETRY THAT'S MORE
RECOGNIZABLE YOU CAN SEE HOW IT
ALSO CINCHES BACK A LITTLE LESS
THAN THE OTHERS AT THAT THE
OTHER SCHEMES SO REVEALING THE
EAST FACADE- AND REALLY IS IN
TUNE WITH THE GEOMETRY OF THE
WEST WING HAS A LOT OF THE SAME
FEATURES. I'LL JUST SPEND THAT
AROUND. I THINK THAT'S GOOD.
REPORTING BY THE- ON
PRESENTATION MODE SO WE CAN
MOVE ON TO A- THIS THEIR
HEARTS- COMMENTS ON BUDGET AND
SCHEDULE. I'M GONNA TRY TO
ADVANCE THE SLIGHT BEFORE. HOW
DO I GET RID OF THE- WELL.
TRANSACTION. ALL RIGHT THERE
YOU GO. BIGELOW DAVID.
FOR A
FORGET I WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK
DONE TO KEEP THINGS- CLEAN I'VE
I APPRECIATE THE TIME AND
EFFORT I'M SURE HE DIDN'T
INTEND TO JUMP UP AND DOWN SO
MUCH AS HE HAS BUT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE HIM TAKING CARE OF
THAT I WANT TO TALK FOR A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE BUDGET AND
SCHEDULE AND THE MANAGEMENT
STRATEGY THAT WE'RE WE'RE USING
FOR THE- ANNEX BUILDING- FIRST
OF ALL BEFORE I START AGAIN I
WANT TO RE AND- REINFORCED THE
FACT THAT THESE ARE CONCEPTUAL
DRAWINGS. WE STILL HAVE A LONG
WAYS TO GO THEY LOOK WONDERFUL
I MEAN THE TECHNOLOGY TODAY
OVER YOU KNOW THE OVERTIME AS
HE EVOLVED TO WHERE THESE LOOK
LIKE THEY'RE FINISHED DRAWINGS
BUT I DON'T WANT TO FOOL YOU
HAVE A LONG WAYS TO GO AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO AND
THERE'S A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY TO
STILL TRY TO BRING THINGS TO
TOGETHER- I WAS ASKED TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PROCESS
THAT WE'RE USING- IN- MANAGING
THE BUDGET AND SCHEDULE IN THE
AND THE PROJECT OVERALL. WE'VE
DEVELOPED A PROCESS- UTILIZE
OVER THE LAST- FOR CAPITAL SO
WE VIEWS CALLED EARLY PROJECT
DEFINITION AN ALIGNMENT WHICH
IS WHAT THE THAT GENERALLY DOES
ARE BASICALLY DOES IS IT TRIES
TO TAKE THE EXPECTATIONS THAT
YOU THE- OWNER HAS AND ALIGN
THAT WITH THE BUDGET AND
SCHEDULE AND QUALITY THAT. YOU
WANT FOR YOUR YOUR BILL IN
DOING THE- WELL WE DO IS IF YOU
LOOK AT THE CHART THAT IS-
DISPLAYED. A BLACK LINE THAT IS
RUNNING THROUGH THERE IS THE
TRADITIONAL. SHOW THAT ON THE
SCREEN.
OOPS YEAH SUCH SHOWING
UP SO THE BLACK LINE THAT YOU
SEE ON THE IN THE GRAPH THERE
ON THE RIGHT IS THE TRADITIONAL
DESIGN PROCESS AND WHAT WE TRY
TO DO IS WE TRY TO MOVE THAT TO
THE LEFT WHICH IS WHERE THE RED
LINE IS SHOWING AND WHAT THAT
DOES IS IT PLACES IT UNDER THE
BLUE CURVE AND- THAT BLUE CURVE
IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO INFLUENCE
OF THE PROJECT AND EARLY IN THE
PROJECT THE MORE WE CAN DO
EARLY ON THE LESTICUS COSTS US
WITH THE MORE INFLUENCE WE HAVE
BECAUSE LESS DECISIOS HAVE
BEEN MADE. SO THE MORE THINGS
WE CAN DO UP FRONT THE MORE
WORK WE CAN PUT INTO IT UP
FRONT THE MORE WE CAN IMPACT
THE COST THE QUALITY IN THE
SCHEDULE IN A POSITIVE WAY IF
WE WAIT AND ALLOW IT TO HAPPEN
IN THE TRADITIONAL SENSE AND WE
ALLOW FOR THOSE DECISIONS TO BE
MADE AFTER THOSE TWO LINES THE
RED IN THE BLUE LINE HAVE
INTERSECTED THEN ALL OF A
SUDDEN THAT COST OF THE CHANGE
BECOMES MUCH HIGHER AND YOU
START TO SEE CHANGE ORDERS AND
YOU START TO SEE PROBLEMS. FOR
THE LAST FOUR CAPITALS UTAH-
IDAHO MINNESOTA AND WYOMING WE
HAVE USED THIS PROCESS FOR
MEMBERS OF OUR TEAM REVIEWS
THIS PROCESS TO HELP DELIVER
THOSE PROJECTS ON BUDGET AND
THAT IS THE PROCESS THAT WE ARE
USING TO HELP MANAGE YOUR
PROJECT AND SO TO GIVE YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF- OUR MANAGEMENT
STRATEGY- MR COOLEY- THE-
CHAIRMAN COOLEY HAD- HAD YOU
PUT TOGETHER A PLANNING STUDY
WHICH WAS PERFECT IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN WHICH-
IS THE BLUE BOOK SHOWN HERE-
THAT IDENTIFIED THE
DEFICIENCIES THAT THE CURRENT
ANNEX HAS. IDENTIFIED THAT MATT
WAS- THAT DRAFT WAS COMPLETED
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
THAT WAS A VERY HELPFUL DRAFT
BECAUSE IT ALLOWED US TO START
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE PROBLEMS
WERE WITH THE BUILDING SO WE
COULD EVALUATE THOSE AND MAKE
THE DECISION AS TO HOW TO MOVE.
MOVE FORWARD. YOU RECEIVED BACK
IN AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE POS THE PROJECT
OVERVIEW IN SEQUENCE REPORT.
THAT WE PUT TOGETHER WHICH
BASICALLY IDENTIFIED THE
QUALITY COST SCHEDULE. AND
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT AND
IDENTIFIED HOW WE WOULD DO THAT
IN A PUT TOGETHER CLEAR
PRINCIPLES AND- GUIDELINES TO
HELP. THE ARCHITECTS AND THE
ENGINEERS AND THE CONTRACTORS
MOVE THOSE THINGS FORWARD. AND
THAT DRAFT AS I MENTIONED WAS
COMPLETED IN AUGUST OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. WE HAVE OVER
THE LAST- I WOULD SAY FOUR
MONTHS FIVE MONTHS DURING THE
SCOLDED PERIOD WE HAVE HELD
EIGHT DIFFERENT WORKSHOPS- WITH
THE DESIGN TEAM AND PRIOR TO
THAT WE HELD FOR FIVE DIFFERENT
WORKSHOPS WITH THE- VISITOR
CENTER TEAM- WE HAVE ONE
WORKSHOP LEFT TO DO WHICH IS A
COST RECONCILIATION WORKSHOP
FOR THE ONYX WHICH- WE CAN'T
REALLY DO UNTIL WE GET DOWN TO
ONE SCHEME BECAUSE IT TENDS TO
BE A LOT OF EFFORT A LOT OF
WORK THAT HAS TO GO INTO THAT.
THAT RETIREES RESULT AND SELL
THOSE THAT'S WHERE WE ARE WITH-
THOSE WORKSHOPS. AND THEN WITH
REGARDS TO MANAGING THE BUDGET-
WE USE CONTINGENCY IN THE
BUDGET DEVELOPMENT TO HELP
MANAGE THE RISK THAT WE KNOW IS
THERE BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW
EVERYTHING AT THIS POINT. AND
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN CONCEPT
DESIGN WHICH IS WHERE WE ARE WE
TRY TO HAVE A LOT OF
CONTINGENCY. SO WE'RE CURRENTLY
CARRYING ABOUT 20% OF THE
BUDGET OR ONE FIFTH OF THE
BUDGET TO ONE QUARTER OF THE
BUDGET IS IN CONTINGENCY RIGHT
NOW. UP FOR EXAMPLE ON SOME OF
THESE GAMES THERE'S A LITTLE
MORE CONTINGENCY BECAUSE
THERE'S A LITTLE LESS KNOWN-
AND THERE'S- ON OTHERS A LITTLE
LESS BUT IT'S ALL BETWEEN
TWENTY AND 24% SCHEMATIC DESIGN
WHICH IS WHERE WE WANT TO GO
NEXT WITH ONE SCHEME. WE WILL
WORK TO BRING THAT CONTINGENCY
DOWN TO ABOUT 15% AND THEN IN
DESIGN DEVELOPMENT. WHICH IS
WHERE WE REALLY GET INTO THE
NUTS AND BOLTS OF HOW THE
BUILDING GOES TOGETHER AND HOW
THINGS. ARE LEARNED. WE WILL
MAIN WE'LL GET DOWN TO ABOUT
10% CONTINGENCY EACH TIME WE DO
THAT. WE ARE ABLE TO ELIMINATE
SOME AND MOVE SOME IN TO THE
DESIGN THEREBY HELPING TO
REDUCE THE OVERALL BUDGET- AND
WE INTEND THEM TO SIGN THE GMP
AND GO INTO CONSTRUCTION WITH
ABOUT FIVE TO SEVEN. PERCENT
CONTINGENCY. SO WHERE ARE WE
CURRENTLY WITH THE ESTIMATE. IF
YOU TAKE ANY ONE OF THESE.
SCHEMES WE ARE BETWEEN ABOUT
FIVE AND 10% IN THE AGGREGATE-
THE ON THE BUDGET BEYOND THE
POS BUDGET. WHICH IS NOT
UNUSUAL FOR THE STATE BECAUSE
AGAIN REMEMBER THIS A LOT WE
STILL DON'T KNOW AND THERE'S A
LOT THAT WE STILL HAVE TO
DISCOVER. THE CONTINGENCY THAT
WE'RE CARRYING IS BETWEEN
TWENTY AND 24% SO YOU CAN SEE
THAT THERE IS A DIFFERENCE OF
ANYWHERE BETWEEN TWENTY. AND
15% WITH REGARDS TO- HOW MUCH
CONTINGENCY OVER THE OVER THE-
OVERREACH THAT WE CURRENTLY
HAVE. WE ARE FAIRLY WE ARE VERY
CONFIDENT THAT WE'LL BE ABLE TO
REDUCE THAT AND GET THE PROJECT
DOWN TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE.
AND AGAIN WE ARE USING THAT
CONTINGENCY AND WE'VE USED IN
THE PAST TO MATCH. THE SO THAT
WE ACTUALLY PUT MORE IN AT THIS
STAGE BECAUSE THERE'S LESS THAT
WE UNDERSTAND. SO IT IS
ANTICIPATED THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD THAT CONTINGENCY WILL
BE ABSORBED INTO THE PROJECT OR
ELIMINATED ALL TOGETHER. AND
WHEN WE GO INTO CONSTRUCTION
WILL BE DOWN TO ABOUT 5% WHAT
I'D LIKE TO DO NOW. IS TO TURN
THE TIME OVER TO TELL YOU TO
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
SCHEDULE AND THE MILESTONES.
THEN I'LL COME BACK IN AND WRAP.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALL HERE WE HAVE
A FIVE YEAR LOOK AHEAD SPANNING
THE DURATION OF THE VISITOR
CENTER WEST WING AND ANNEXED
PROJECTS- I WILL GO INTO
FURTHER DETAIL OF ALL THE
MILESTONES ON THE NEXT SLIDE
HOWEVER IT IS OF NOTE THAT THE
VISITOR CENTER AND THE NEW
ANNEXED PROJECTS WILL BE PHASED
DESIGN PROJECTS MEANING THAT-
DO YOU DESIGN AND PERMITTING
ACTIVITIES WILL OVERLAP BE
CONSTRUCTION WORK EARLY START
OF THE CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITY.
CURRENTLY THE SEEK WHAT YOUR
MEDICATIONS ARE BEING DRAFTED
AND FINALIZED. WHICH WILL THEN
PROVIDE TREATMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES AND TO
PRESERVATION STRATEGIES PROJECT
WIDE. THIS WILL IMPACT THE
CONSTRUCTION STARTS AT THE
VISITOR CENTER AND THE NEW
ANNEX CONSTRUCTION. DESIGN AND
PERMITTING FOR ENABLING PRE
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES IS ALSO
UNDER WAY WITHIN THE WEST WING
AND ANNEXED AREAS WHICH IS
SHOWN IN BLUE IN THIS GRAPHIC.
THIS PRE CONSTRUCTION WORK IS
SET TO START IN MARCH OF NEXT
YEAR. AND AT THIS TIME I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE GRANT REFUND HE
FROM TURNER THE- CONSTRUCTION
MANAGER AT RISK TEAM TO SPEAK
ON. TURNER'S CLASS ACTIVITIES.
GOOD AFTERNOON HI I'M THE
DALLAS ACTUALLY STARTS WITH A
SERIES OF SMALLER PROJECTS POKE
THAT WERE CALLING A NAVAL AND
WORK THEIR WAY MORE CONSISTS OF
RELOCATING EXISTING UTILITIES
MECHANICAL ELECTRICAL SITE
UTILITIES FROM THE EXISTING
ANNEX INTO THE WEST WING. THAT
WORK WILL ALLOW THE WORST
WARNED TO REMAIN FUNCTIONAL AND
OPERATIONAL WHILE WE TEAR DOWN
AND. REPLACE ANNEX WITH NEW
CONSTRUCTION. THE ENABLING WORK
ALSO CONSISTS OF INSTALLING
TEMPORARY PER. AND EXIT
STERRETT. ON THE NORTH AND
SOUTH SIDES OF THE WEST WING
NOT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE WEST WING AND DO
BUSINESS WALL THE ANNEX IS
UNDER CONSTRUCTION. THE I.
ANNEX CONSTRUCTION ARE IS
DEPENDENT ON THE DESIGN AND
PERMITTING THE CURRENT WHICH IS
DEPENDENT ON THE SELECTION OF
ONE OF THE THREE OPTIONS. THAT
JOSE AND CHLOE EXPLAINED TODAY.
I WE'VE PLAN FOR ABOUT THIRTY
THREE MONTHS OF DESIGN AND
PERMITTING. I KNOW THAT SEEMS
LIKE A LONG TIME BUT FOR A
PROJECT OF THIS MAGNITUDE IS
VERY AGGRESSIVE. SO IT'S
IMPORTANT WE MAKE THAT
DECISION. AT THE 50% CD FRASER
CONSTRUCTION DOCUMENT PHASE OF
THE DESIGN WILL PUT TOGETHER
THE GUARANTEED MAXIMUM PRICE.
WHICH WILL ALLOW THE FUNDING TO
BE- FINALIZE FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES. WE'VE
ALSO PLAN FOR THIRTY EIGHT
MONTHS OF CONSTRUCTION ON THE
INTERNET THE NEW ANNEX. LONG
COMPLETION OF THE GMP APPROVAL
THE GMP. AND THE COMPLETION OF
THE ENABLING WORK WILL BE ABLE
TO GET STARTED WITH THE
DEMOLITION. OF THE EXISTING
ADDICTS AND MOVE FORWARD WITH
OUR CONSTRUCTION THIRTY EIGHT
MONTHS THAT MEANS E COMPLETE
IN APRIL TO JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. WHICH ALLOWS FOR
FOUR MONTHS OF. A STAFFING AND
STOCKING THE NEW ANNEX
COMMISSION AND THAT. ALLOWS FOR
OCCUPANCY. AND NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
YEAH. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JACK GARRITY WITH PLANT
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY WORKING
WITH THE CAVAGNOUD TEAM AND
JUST WANTED TO TALK BRIEFLY
ABOUT THE SCHEDULE HERE FOR THE
VISITOR CENTER- WITH YOUR
APPROVAL. WE WOULD. BEGIN
DESIGN AND PERMITTING WITH THE
IDEA THAT WE WOULD BEGIN
CONSTRUCTION IN THE MIDDLE OF
NEXT YEAR CONSTRUCTION WOULD
TAKE APPROXIMATELY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OR SO. AND WE WOULD BE
FINISHED BY THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO WITH PHASE
ONE. PHASE TWO- IF IT'S FUNDED
WITHIN PROCEED AT- IDEALLY
DOVETAIL WITH THE PHASE ONE BUT
COULD HAPPEN ANYTIME. AN
OCCUPANCY. WOULD BEGIN AT THE
BEGINNING OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU.
NOW TO
SUPPLEMENT THE OPPOSITE R.
CENTER THE EARLY START OF THE
VISITOR CENTER OR THE START OF
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE VISITOR
CENTER IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THE FINISHING OF THE VISITOR
CENTER IN THE FIRST QUARTER OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WOULD ALLOW
FOR ABOUT THREE YEARS OF- ENTRY
EXIT ACCESS THROUGH THE
VISITORS CENTER TORE TO EXCUSE
ME BE CAPITOL BUILDING WHILE B.
ALEX IS BEING CONSTRUCTED FOR
DEMOLISHED AND CONSTRUCTED
ITSELF. NOW MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT SLIDE WE HAVE MILES THE
MILESTONES LEADING UP TO THE
OCCUPANT MOVE OF THE DETECTED
NO SWING SPACE AND ABATEMENT
AND DEMOLITION OF THE EXISTING
ANNEX. AS DAVID HAD MENTIONED
IN THE PREVIOUS SECTION OR
SEGMENT- WORKSHOP NUMBER NINE
COST RECONCILIATION WILL BE.
SCHEDULED MID OCTOBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY AND ARTIST PENDANT UPON
PENDING UPON THE FINAL
SELECTION OF THE DESIGN OF THE
ANNEX. FOLLOWING THAT IN IT MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- THE VISITOR
CENTER WOULD START IF APPROVED
AND- ONE BTC QUIET EFFORTS HAVE
BEEN FINALIZED. THEY MOVED TO
THE SWING SPACE WILL TAKE PLACE
MID OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THE G. M. P. IN MARCH FIFTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AND FINALLY
THE ABATEMENT DEMOLITION
CONSTRUCTION START OF THE- NEW
ANNEX BUILDING IN THE SECOND
QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AROUND MARCH. DEGREE CRITICS
SCHEDULING SEGMENT OF THE
PRESENTATION THE CURRENT
ENABLING WORK- PRECEDES THE
START OF THE OCCUPANT MOVED TO
THE SWING SPACE. WITH YOUR
APPROVAL THE VISITOR CENTER
WOULD START MAY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ALLOWING FOR UP ANOTHER
ENTRY OPPORTUNITY AN EXITING
OPPORTUNITY TO THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. AND OCCUPANCY WILL BE
TAKING PLACE IN THE ALEX IN
LATE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. NOW
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
REINTRODUCE DAVID HART.
THANK
YOU I'D LIKE TO THANK EVERYBODY
WHO IS PRESENTED TODAY- YOU CAN
SEE THAT WE'VE SET A VERY
AGGRESSIVE SCHEDULE TO TRY TO
OPEN- IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ON
SEPTEMBER NINTH WHICH IS- YOUR
ADMISSIONS DAIS WOULD BE NICE
TO HAVE A CELEBRATION ON THAT
DAY- WE RECOGNIZE THAT YOU. DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM TODAY BUT
NONE THE LESS WE ARE AND YOU TO
CONSIDER THE- THE DOUBLE T. THE
CIRCLE IN THE SQUARE WE NEED
YOUR DIRECTION BEFORE THE END
OF THE MONTH SO THAT WE CAN
STAY ON SCHEDULE AND KEEP
THINGS MOVING FORWARD. WE WOULD
ALSO LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER THE
VISITOR CENTER AND GIVE US SOME
DIRECTION AS TO HOW YOU WOULD
LIKE US TO PROCEED ON THAT. SO
WITH THAT I'LL TURN THE TIME
BACK OVER TO- CHAIRMAN COOLEY
AND WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. FOR THANK YOU ALL
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION
FOR WALKING US THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM AND- TODAY IT IS
IMPORTANT TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BRING TO THE
DRUG RULES COMMITTEE THIS
INFORMATION. IT HAS NOT BEEN IN
THE PUBLIC REALM BECAUSE THE
HASN'T YET COME TO THE JOINT
RULES COMMITTEE SEOUL AND WHILE
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM AS SUCH
STILL THIS IS A CONVENIENT. AND
I AM I AM INFORMED THAT THERE
IS SOME MAYBE SOME BAND WITH
ISSUES BEING EXPRESSED ONLINE
BUT ALL THE MATERIAL THE YOU'VE
JUST SEN IS AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC ONLINE IT'S NOW IN THE
PUBLIC REALM AND SO. TODAY
PROVIDES A VERY IMPORTANT
MILESTONE FROM THAT STANDPOINT-
I'D LIKE TO START AT THIS POINT
WITH QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. AND I KNOW I HAVE
SOME MEMBERS THAT ARE ONLINE
I'M GONNA SEE IF I CAN MOVE
THEM UP. WHO WOULD- MR GRAYSON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND I DO HAVE
A COUPLE QUESTIONS IF I MAY- TO
THE PRESENTERS. OUT ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS OF GOING BACK TO
CONTINGENCY AND YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT- THE 20%
CONTINGENCY THAT IS- I BELIEVE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET- FOR THE
ANNEX. AND YOU'RE TRYING TO GET
THAT CONTINGENCY DOWN TO ABOUT
5% WHICH WOULD BE A 50%
DECREASE IN THE CONTINGENCY.
DOES THE AND RIGHT NOW IF I
UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY YOU'RE
ABOUT FIVE OR 10% ABOVE THE
BUDGET AS FAR AS WHERE WE'RE
AT- WHICH MEANS THAT- THE MORE-
THE QICKER WE MOVE TO. A
CHOSEN PLAN AND THE MORE WE
ELIMINATE THAT CONSENT OR
DECREASE THE CONTINGENCY-
YOU'RE ACTUALLY LOOKING AT
BEING ABLE TO BRING A PROJECT
DESIGNED. AND THAT MAY BE- ATTY
OR MAYBE JUST A LITTLE BIT
UNDER BUDGET IS THAT CORRECT.
YEAH THIS IS MISTER HART JERRY
IT'S HOW HE HAS MANAGED
PROJECTS THIS ACTION VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION. SO I'LL LET
HIM SPEAK TO THAT YES THANK
YOU- YOU'RE YOU'RE CORRECT WE
USE CONTINGENCY TO HELP OFFSET
THE RISK OF THE UNKNOWNS THAT
WE HAVE AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT
THOSE- ITEMS. THAT CONTINGENCY
WILL EITHER BE ELIMINATED-
BECAUSE WE WILL KNOW AND WILL
BE ABLE TO HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING. BUT IN SOME
CASES IT ALSO BE INCORPORATED
SORE OUR GOAL IS TO KIND OF
WORK BOTH WAYS TOWARDS THE
BUDGET SO THAT WHEN WE ARE
COMPLETE AND WE SIGNED THE GMP
THAT WE ARE ON BUDGET. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND TO THE CHAIR
ONE MORE QUESTION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ON THE CIRCULAR
DESIGN IT- IT APPEARS TO BE
CLEAR THAT THE BOTTOM TWO
LEVELS. ARE UN INTERRUPTED FOR
SPACE ALL THE WAY AROUND. BUT
THE TOP LEVELS ABOVE THE BOTTOM
TWO LEVELS. IT APPEARS LIKE- IT
BECOMES TWO SEPARATE ALMOST TWO
SEPARATE BUILDINGS ARE EACH OF
THOSE FOUR LEVELS CONNECTED BY.
A WALKWAY WORSE SOMETHING OF
THAT SORT. I WAS. JOSE DO YOU
WANT TO ANSWER THE QUESTION YOU
CAN YOU CAN PROBABLY DO IT FROM
THERE. THIS IS MICRO M. I'M NOT
SURE I A- TIMELY AND- DAY HEARD
YOUR QUESTION BUT- IT ALSO LONG
TERM YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
SPACE INSIDE YES- IF I'M
WALKING AROUND THE PERIMETER
INSIDE INSIDE. THIS PART RIGHT
HERE THESE TWO SECTIONS RIGHT
HERE YEAH ARE THERE WALKWAYS
BETWEEN THE WHERE THERE'S NO
ACTUAL- OFFICE SPACE. THERE SO
YOU CAN CONTINUE TO GO ALL THE
WAY AROUND OKAY ALL THE WAY
AROUND FOR SURE YES YEAH WELL
THAT THAT MAKES ME LIKE THAT
DESIGN EVEN MORE THAN I ALREADY
LOVE IT- SO- MISTER CHAIR IT'S
JUST- FOR MY OPINION FIRST OF
ALL WHEN IT COMES THE VISITORS
CENTER- I REALLY LIKE THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE- ALONG WITH-
THE DESIGN TEAM. ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT WE PRIORITIZE THE
PEOPLE FIRST. AND THAT WE WORK
ON THE VISITOR CENTER WE GIVE%
ACCESS AND I AM FULLY
SUPPORTIVE OF MOVING FORWARD
WITH THE VISITORS CENTER AND AS
WELL WOULD LIKE TO JUST PUT MY
OPINION ABOUT THE CIRCULAR HOW
THAT- I AM VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT DESIGN AND WHAT IT DOES
FOR. THE CAPITAL PARKING.
PROJECT AND FOR THE PEOPLE AS
WELL. I WANT TO SAY I. JUST IN
RESPONSE OF THAT. WHERE I FEEL
WE ARE AT THE VISITOR CENTER
IS. IF WE NEED TO MAKE A
DECISION ON WHICH DESIGN. THAT
IS WHAT THE CREW DAYS FOR THE
END OF PROJECT AND SHE- AS- YOU
GO BACK TO MARCH. THINK OF
THOSE HEADLINES ECONOMY WAS
COLLAPSING. JOBS ARE BEING LOST.
FALL IN A WAY THE SURPLUS IS A
WEIRD AMASSED IN JEOPARDY YOU
JUST THAT TIME OF YEAR. AND THE
GOVERNOR SAID LET'S KEEP A
CHECK ON OUR SPENDING. THIS IS
HIS JOB AS CHIEF EXECUTIVE AND
SO FOR THIS REASON THE VISITOR
CENTER WHICH WHILE IT PLAYS AT
INTEGRAL ROLE IN THE STRATEGY
TO GET RID OF BOTTLENECKS AND
CONGESTION. OF AND OVERCROWDING.
IS SORT OF A PLUS ELEMENT. TO
THE LARGER ENERGY PROJECTS OF
ASHLEY PUT ON PAUSE SO I JUST
WANNA SAY I ACTUALLY FAVOR THAT
BUT I THINK THAT'S A- IF. IT'S
UNDER THE LAW. THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE IS TO HAVE THE
PREEMINENT ROLE IN DECISIONS
ABOUT THIS PROJECT THAT'S
ACTUALLY WORE TO DISTRACTION
PREEMINENT. THAT BEING THE CASE
IT DOES SAY ANNEX PARKING
GARAGE RESERVE CENTER. BUT IT
SAYS TIMING COULD VERY SO I
SORT OF FEEL IF IT IS THE VIEW
OF THE JOINT RULES COMMITTEE AS
WE FINALLY CONVENE WITH A
QUORUM. AND HAVE A SETTLED VIEW.
DID WITH SERVICE CENTER I
BELIEVE IT IS INCUMBENT UPON US
TO ENGAGE WITH THE GOVERNOR
CONVERSATION. BECAUSE OF WE ARE
PARTNERS WITH THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH. THE PROJECT WILL
GREATLY ENHANCE THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH SPACES BUT I FEEL ALL.
IT'S I AM PROTECTIVE OF OUR
PROVOCATIVE IS A JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE TO GIVE LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA. BUT WE HAVE TO
RESPECT ALL OUR PARTNERS SO I
THINK IT'S EASIER TO SEE HOW WE
ARE WE KNOW A CLEARPATH ON THE
ANNEX PROJECT PROBLEM PARKING
GARAGE. I PERSONALLY FEEL THERE
IS IN MY HEAD AN ASTERISK
AROUND THE VISITOR CENTER. OUT
OF RESPECT FOR THE OFFICE OF
GOVERNOR. AND OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH THEM. SO WHAT I'M GONNA DO
I WILL GET YOU IN A MOMENT.
CENTER MONNING YOU'D RAISE YOUR
HAND. YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AND JUST RE FRAMING
MAYBE WHAT YOU WERE
ARTICULATING. MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THE MAY REVISE INCLUDED
GREEN LINE FUNDING FOR THE
ANNEX BUT NOT FOR THE VISITOR
CENTER SO. BEFORE US CURRENTLY
TODAY OR WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WE DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO COMMIT FUNDING. TO
THE VISITOR CENTER THAT SAID IT
SEEMS LIKE IT IS AN IMPORTANT
SUBJECT FOR ONGOING
DELIBERATION AND ISSUE
SUGGESTED DIALOGUE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THE URGENCY
THE NINE HEARING FOR MOVING
FORWARD WITH DESIGNING
INSISTING ON TIME TABLE ON THE
ANNEX PROJECT IS WHERE A
DECISION IS NECESSARY AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE SO THAT AS SOON AS
WE CAN CONVENE A QUORUM OF THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE. THAT
WOULD BE THE VOTE TO ALLOW
PROJECT PLANNING TO MOVE
FORWARD- WITH AN ON. THE DESIGN
I GUESS DEVELOP FOR THE ANNEX
IS DEPENDENT ON WHETHER THERE'S
A VISITOR CENTER OR NOT SO
THERE'S STILL A DYNAMIC.
BETWEEN THE TWO- AND THERE'S
OBVIOUSLY A LOT OF GOOD
ARGUMENTS FROM SECURITY POINT
OF VIEW ACCESS. IN THE USE OF
SPACE IN THE ANNEX THAT THERE
BE SOME COMMITMENT TO THE
VISITORS CENTER BUT- AGAIN MY
QUESTION- MY STATEMENT IS I
DON'T THINK THAT'S WITHIN OUR
AUTHORITY TODAY OR IN COMING
WEEKS BUT TO MOVE TO GET
EVERYTHING MOVING FORWARD WE
WILL FRAME A VOTE ON A CHOICE
AMONG THE THREE ANNEX OPTIONS-
IN CONTINUE TO DISCUSS HOW.
THAT DEVELOPMENT IS IMPACTED
WITH OR WITHOUT A VISITORS
CENTER IN MY STATING THAT I
FRANKLY REALLY CORRECT WE HAVE
AN APPROPRIATION ACTUALLY OF
THE- FUNDS FOR THE ENTIRE
PROJECT. THE APPROPRIATIONS OR
PASSED IN SIXTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
FUNDED THE ENTIRE PROJECT. IN
THE DOWNTURN THE REQUEST WAS
CAN A EXECUTIVE BRANCH HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT CASH. WHICH I
SAID YES. CAN WE PUT THE
VISCERAL PAUSE THAT SEEMED
REASONABLE AGAIN THIS IS THE
MIDDLE OF MARCH AND I'M ON THE
FOR THE GOVERNORS FINANCE
DIRECTOR- BUT THE CONVERSATION
AS WELL. WE DO HAVE PLANNING
DESIGN WORK IN A WAY WE CAN OF
COURSE CONTINUE THAT. BECAUSE
IT'S AN ELEMENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S STATE FOR A
STORY- NINETY ONE TWELVE. ANNEX
PARKING GARAGES OR CENTER. AND
THEY'VE BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
PLANNING CONTINUING. SO I DO
FEEL AS A PRACTICAL MATTER WE
JUST. WE DO NEED TO WORK WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON AGREEMENT
TO FUND THE VISITOR CENTER THAT
IT'S- CLAIRE WE ALREADY HAVE
AUTHORITY UNDER STATUTE ENACTED
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THAT. WE
CAN USE LEASE REVENUE BONDS FOR
THE PROJECT. AND AT THE FORTY
IS ALSO IN PLACE SO WE
SUPPORTED OUR STATE IN
RESPONDING TO A STATE OF
EMERGENCY WE HAVE THESE REVENUE
BONTA FORTY AVAILABLE THAT'S
ALSO WHEN THE MAYES. BUDGET
REVISE NO- BUT I YEAH I MEAN I
FEEL IT'S- BY LAW JOINT RULES
HAS THE STATE FOR A FORTY ITS
HOW WE'VE ALWAYS DONE THE ANNEX
THE WEST WING WAS A LEGISLATIVE
PROJECT. THE LAW REFLECTS THAT
I THINK IT'S FAIR FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY. TO
CONSIDER WHERE THEY FEEL WE
OUGHT TO BE GOING AND IF WE
FAVOR MOVING FORWARD AS
AGGRESSIVE AS YOU CAN WITH THE
VISITOR CENTER AND IT IS A
CONVERSATION WITH THE GOVERNOR
ALONG THOSE LINES I THINK
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE HELPFUL
FROM THE MANAGEMENT TEAM. MIGHT
BE. SOME COST PROJECTIONS OF.
DOING VISITORS CENTER THIS.
ACCORDING TO THE PROPOSED
SCHEDULE VERSUS A DELAY IN
POTENTIAL COST INCREASES THAT
MIGHT. FURTHER INFORMED
DIALOGUE BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE. IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE THEN IF I COULD MOVE TO
A QUICK QUESTION MISTER CHAIR
JUST ON THE THREE DESIGN
CHOICES ON THE ANNEX- ON THE
CIRCLE DESIGN- IN TERMS OF
CONFIGURATION OF OFFICE SPACE-
ARE THERE ANY ISSUES. OF THE
RAM ONE FOR FURNITURE AND- ARE
THE COSTS ROUGHLY EQUIVALENT OF
THE THREE OPTIONS AND- DO ANY
OF THE OPTIONS HAVE UNIQUE.
SPATIAL COST ISSUES THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF SENATOR
MONNING. THEY ALL HAVE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT- COST IMPLICATIONS
FOR EXAMPLE THE DOUBLE T. HAS A
VERY LARGE ATRIUM SO WE'RE
PAYING FOR THAT ATRIUM THE
VENTILATION AND THE SMOKE
EVACUATION SYSTEM IN THE ROUND
SCHEME- IT IS ONLY A TWO STORY
SPACE SO IT'S TECHNICALLY NOT
AN ATRIUM THEREFORE NO WE'RE
NOT PAYING FOR AN ATRIUM
EVACUATION SITUATION. HOWEVER
THE ROUND SCHEME DOES POSE
CERTAIN- COMPLEXITIES WITH
REGARDS TO CONNECTIONS AND-
WITH REGARDS TO HOW YOU TAKE
FLAT MATERIALS AND ENDITEM AND
TO CURB MATERIAL SO YOU YOU
YOU'RE ASKING AN EXCELLENT
QUESTION WE ARE ACTUALLY
CARRYING ABOUT TWENTY FOUR
POINT 5% CONTINGENCY ON THE
ROUND SCHEMES OR CARRYING MORE
CONTINGENCY THERE. BECAUSE
THERE IS MORE ON THE- AND SO
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOUNT FOR
THOSE THINGS AS WE TALKED ABOUT
WITH REGARDS TO THAT
CONTINGENCY IN AS WE LEARN MORE
WE'LL- MOVE THAT HOPEFULLY
NUMBER DOWN THANK YOU IN. FOR A
YIELD BACK TO THE CHAIR JUST A
FINAL COMMENT ON THE THREE
DESIGNS. THE IS IT THE DOUBLE
T. THAT HAS THE FORCE. FOR
FLOOR ATRIUM. SO JUST A THOUGHT
FROM A CONCERT THE SECURITY
POINT OF VIEW. THE PUBLIC AREA
AS IT FILLS UP IF THERE ARE.
PROTEST DEMONSTRATIONS PEOPLE
EXERCISING PEACEFUL FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS THERE COULD BE
A PREFERENCE TO HAVING UPPER
FLOORS SEALED OFF FROM THAT
PARTICIPATORY- SHOULD GAUGE
MEANT IF YOU WILL- SO I THINK
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING
THERE IT'S- RIGHT SPACES OPEN
FOR TWO FLOORS VERSUS FOR
SOMETHING ALONG THOSE LINES- SO
THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR GOOD- I'M
GONNA GO TO WINDY. AND I'M
GONNA GO TO YOU CENTER MORLOCK
IS MY FINANCE EXPERT MADAM.
KAMLAGER HIS CARILLO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
THE INCREDIBLE PRESENTATION
TODAY SENATOR MONNING HAD
TOUCHED UPON SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT I WANT TO RAISE AS WELL- I
BELIEVE IT'S MEXICO CITY'S
CONGRESS THAT'S DESIGNED IN THE
CIRCULAR WAY. OUT WHEN I WENT
TO GO VISIT IT JUST FELT LIKE
IT TOOK A REALLY LONG TIME TO
GET TO THE OFFICE. AND I'M JUST
WONDERING THE WALKABILITY OF
EACH DESIGN AND WHICH WHICH
DESIGN I PREFER MY PREFERENCES
THAT THE CIRCULAR ONE-
PRIMARILY BECAUSE IT HELPS SAVE
THE MOST TREES. WHICH IS I
THINK A AN IMPORTANT PART OF
THIS BEAUTIFUL SPACE- AND SO
I'M JUST CURIOUS IF THERE'S ANY
DIFFERENCES IN TERMS OF THE
WALKABILITY- AS YOU KNOW STAFF
RUNS AROUND AND- AND WE ALL DO
RUNNING FROM OFFICE TO OFFICE
TRYING TO DO OUR OUR JOBS ON A
DAILY BASIS AND JUST WHAT THE
<c.red>MPACT EACH OF THOSE. THOSE ARE</c>
SIGNS ARE. SURE THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION. THE WE HAVEN'T I
HAVEN'T GONE THROUGH AND HAVE
THE ARCHITECTS FIGURE OUT THE
AMOUNT OF LINEAL DISTANCE ON
ANY OF THE SCHEMES YOU HAVEN'T
DONE THAT HAVE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
NOT YET SO I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER SPECIFICALLY BUT WE HAVE
CREATED A SERIES OF- CROSS
CORRIDOR IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DESIGN AS WELL SO YOU HAVE THE
CIRCULAR 8EME
ABILITY TO WALK ALL THE WAY
AROUND THE BUILDING. BUT WITHIN
THAT CIRCULATION WE HAVE
CIRCULATION AND IS HAPPENING ON
TWO SIDES SO YOU CAN CROSS
THROUGH AND GO BACK. SO IF YOU
WANT TO WALK ALL THE WAY AROUND
THE PERIMETER OR THE INTERIOR
IT PROBABLY ISN'T- UP MAYBE A
LITTLE MORE BECAUSE OF THE
CIRCULAR NATURE THAN MAYBE THE
DOUBLE T. BUTTON THE DOUBLE T.
ALSO HAS A CIRCULATION OF GOES
DOWN EITHER SIDE AND THEN HAS
WINGS THAT YOU HAVE TO GO BACK
UP INTO. AND SO LIKE MY GUESS
IS THE CIRCULATION IS PROBABLY-
RELATIVELY CLOSE TO EACH OTHER
EVEN THOUGH IT'S A LITTLE MORE-
HIDDEN IN IN THE DOUBLE T. THE
OTHER THING THAT I WILL TELL
YOU IS THAT- ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE GAVE TO THE
ARCHITECTS. IS THIS CONCEPT OF
ADJACENCY TO EVERYTHING TRYING
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY TO GET FROM POINT A TO
POINT B. QUICKLY AND SO THAT'S
WHY A LOT OF THESE CROSS
CONNECTIONS OCCUR WITHIN THE
WHAT WHAT WE TO THE SIR OF THE
FIGURE A- SO THAT IF YOU ARE IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE CIRCLE AND
YOU NEED TO GO ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER YOU HAVE THAT ABILITY TO
MOVE OR IF YOU NEED TO GO
ACROSS TO DOUBLE CROSSED
WITHOUT HAVING TO WALK AROUND.
SO WE TRY TO MAKE IT AS
CONVENIENT AS POSSIBLE BUT I DO
THINK THERE'S PROBABLY SOME
INHERENT ADDITIONAL.
CIRCULATION IN THE CIRCLE. I
WANTED IF I MAY SO WOMAN. WAY
BACK IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THIS
STUDY WAS DONE FOR US WHERE IS
JUST VERY COLORFUL CHART. AND
THE UPSHOT OF THIS CHART IS
THAT WHAT IS QUITE UNIQUE IN
OUR STATE CAPITOL IS THIS IDEA
WE HEARD REFERRED TO THE
ADJACENCY OF EVERYTHING. A
MEMBER CAN ARRIVE IN THE
BASEMENT RIDE THE ELEVATOR GET
TO YOUR OFFICE. FROM THE OFFICE
OF AND AFTER HEARING ROOM. THEN
GO TO ANOTHER ROOM THEN GO
CHECK OF READERSHIP GO SEE
LET'S SAY COUNCIL GET TO THE
CAUCUS ROOM. THERE IS JUST
EXTRAORDINARY ABILITY TO GET
ALL AROUND THE BILL INTO ALL
THE DIFFERENT PIECES THAT MAKE
UP YOUR DAY. AND ALSO AS A
LAWMAKER. OUR JOB IS SORT OF
MAKE OUR DAY PRODUCTIVE. SO I
WANT TO POINT THIS OU BECAUSE
THIS WHOLE PROJECT FROM DAY
ONE. HAS LOOKED AT THE
IMPORTANCE OF NOT LOSING THIS
QUALITY OF OUR CAPITAL. OF
EVERYTHING WITHIN EASY REACH.
SO THE WHATEVER THE DEMANDS OF
AN INDIVIDUAL LAWMAKER NOW IN
THE FUTURE THEY CAN GET A LOT
DONE WITH THEIR AVAILABLE TIME.
SO I WANT TO SAY THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT QUESTION NOT TO
DISMISS BUT TO SAY KEEP
THINKING ABOUT THAT. ALL THESE
QUARTERS RESIGNED TO PROVIDE
CENTRAL CORRIDORS MULTIPLE WAYS
TO GET AROUND SO YOU AVOID
CONGESTION- BUT I JUST WANT TO
SAY. YOU'VE HIT UPON WHAT WE
ACTUALLY BELIEVE. IS ONE OF THE
KEY THINGS THAT MAKES
CALIFORNIA'S CAP ON UNIQUE.
MANY OTHER CAPITALS IT'S MUCH
MORE SPRAWLING OF THE WHOLE DC
EXPERIENCE- BUT MANY OTHER
CAPITAL SEPARATE THING. AND I
ALSO WANT TO SAY AND I KNOW
CENTER HERTZBERG WILL JOIN US.
I HAVE BEEN ASKED TO JUST POINT
OUT THAT. ALSO GOING BACK TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. IT CONCERNS
EXISTED FROM IN THIS BOOK. ON.
GIVEN THE LONG HISTORY SECONDS
A PLACE OF HUMAN HABITATION.
THERE IS A VERY REAL
POSSIBILITY OF. CULTURAL
RESOURCE OR ARTIFACTS MAY BE
PRESENT ON THE GROUNDS. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF EMPHASIS ON
MAKING SURE WE ARE CAREFUL WITH
THE FACT TO TRIBAL ROLEX OR
OTHER EVIDENCES ANYWAY THIS
POINT WE'VE HAD FORENSIC DOGS
CONDUCTED SURVEYS OF THE
GROUNDS. LOOKING FOR POSSIBLE
ISSUES WE'VE DONE GROUND
PENETRATING RADAR TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS BELOW GRADE
WITH THIS IN MIND- I SAY THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THAT THERE IS.
IT IS IT IS AN ISSUE OF GREAT
SENSITIVITY AND I PERSONALLY
HAVE FELT I NEED A WORKER BY
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE BEFORE
I'M- DOING TOO MUCH WITH OTHER
PARTIES SAID NEEDED. MAKE SURE
JOINT RULES IS UP TO SPEED- BUT
THIS HAS BEEN A CONCERN FROM
DAY ONE AS IT WAS SAID THE
DRAFT OF THIS WAS COMPLETED
SEVENTEEN. PUBLISHED IN
DECEMBER OF SEVENTEEN AND HAS
BEEN A PARAMOUNT CONCERN FROM
THE BEGINNING- SO OF. YOUR
COURSE WAS ADDRESS. SENATOR
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MATT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. YOU'VE
APPARENTLY BEEN HAVING A
DIALOGUE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE ON THIS WHOLE PROJECT SO
I KIND OF WANT TO. TALK ABOUT
THAT OR TALK ABOUT THE TIMING
THE TREES AND THE TYPE REAL
QUICK I'M IN A DIFFICULT
ECONOMIC CYCLE IT IT IS IT IS A
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE-
CONSTITUENTS TO UNDERSTAND WHY
YOU'RE- BUILDING SOMETHING
WHEN. EMPLOYEES ARE TAKING
FURLOUGHS AND YOU'RE MAKING
CAT. SO I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT AND HOW DO WE- INFORM THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT FUNDING HAS
BEEN APPROPRIATED THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING WE'RE DOING. AT A
TIME OF SCARCITY BUT WE HAVE
ALREADY SAID BONDS ASIDE TO DO
THIS. AND THAT IT ACTUALLY
WOULD PUT PEOPLE TO WORK AND-
IN A GREAT ECONOMIC VITALITY-
WE BUILT TERMINAL C. AT JOHN
WAYNE AIRPORT ORANGE COUNTY
DURING THE GREAT RECSSION. AND
WHEN I WOULD TOURED EVERY SIX
WEEKS. THE WORKERS RED BANK ME
THAT THEY WERE WORKING THEY HAD
A JOB FOR ENTERING WORKING
SIDE. I NEED YOU TO HELP ME
UNDERSTAND. HOW I CAN
COMMUNICATE THIS AND THAT
WHAT'S THE GOVERNOR THINKING
AND IF THE GOVERNOR PUTS A HOLD
ON EVERYTHING THEN. THIS IS ALL
ACADEMIC. AND DINNER SO IN THAT
REGARD I WOULD ALSO. GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF IDEAS ONE IS THAT WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON THE VISITOR
CENTER AT THE SAME TIME. TWO S.
THE TYPE CIRCLE SQUARED A
DOUBLE T. EITHER ONE WORKS FOR
ME SO I DON'T HAVE LIKE A
STRONG BIAS. BUT WOULD YOU
LEAST BEFORE WE HEAR SPEAKERS
COULD YOU PLEASE GIVE ME YOUR
PERSPECTIVES AS WELL ON THE
TREES AND THE CONCERN THAT
PEOPLE ARE HAVING. ABOUT THE
PARK. YEAH. ON THE- ON THE
TREES FROM A E. I. R.
STANDPOINT YOU END UP PUTTING A
LARGE. MARK ON THE GROUND WHERE
THE PROJECT WILL BE SITUATED.
OF FROM DAY ONE. WE HAVE
FOCUSED ON HOW TO MINIMIZE THE
IMPACT ON THE TREES LOOKING
VERY CLOSELY AT THE FOOT PRINT
SERVER EXAMPLE THE VISITOR
CENTERS TO THE DEODAR CEDARS
ARE OUT FOR THE VISITOR CENTER.
WE'RE NOT EXPECTED TO TOUCH
THOSE TO BYRON SHIRE TREATED
MARKETEER TREE OF THE SELF
INTEREST OF WHOLE LINE OF NOT
GOING TO TOUCH THOSE OR THAT
SOUTH LAWN. THE PARKING GARAGE
WHERE'S THE BEST PLACE TO PLACE
IT. WAS A CONVERSATION SELF ON
NORTH LAWN. ORDER TWELVE STREET
ALIGNMENT. IT'S NOT A REAL
PROBLEM BUT IF YOU ACTUALLY
LOOK AT THE PARKING GARAGE
YOU'LL SEE A NOTCH. ON THE EAST
SIDE ADJACENT TO THE TULIP
TREE. WE HAVE A GRAND TOTAL OF
THREE OUT THERE THE LAWN. NEAR
THE FISH POND WHICH IS THE
NOTCHES DESIGNED TO SAFEGUARD
THAT TREE. SO THE. THE PLAN OF
THIS PROJECT IS TO BE
COMPATIBLE WITH THE PARK TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE. AND I
PERSONALLY FEEL A CONSIDERATION
IS THE AESTHETIC OF THE- HOW
THE BUILDING LOOKS INSIDE THE
PARK I SORT OF LIKE A CIRCLE
BUT I TOO AM OPEN TO WHATEVER
DESIGN PEOPLE WANT TO GO WITH.
BUT I LIKE THE FACT THAT IT'S
SORT OF RECEIPTS AWAY IT
DOESN'T LOOK QUITE SO. A
MASSIVE. SO YEAH I WOULD SAY
THE GOAL OF THIS PROJECT IS TO
BE. SAFEGUARD THE TREES TO THE
UTMOST EXTENT POSSIBLE AND I
ADMIT THAT WHEN YOU LOOK AT ANY
AYE ARE YOU SEE A LARGE AREA
THAT IS MARKED. THAT MIGHT
INVOLVE THE PROJECT FROM L. TO
N. TO TEN. AND OF COURSE THE
WALKWAY BUT WE'RE NOT GONNA
DISTURB ALL THAT GROUND. AND I
ACTUALLY FEEL THAT THE REMOVAL
OF THE DRIVEWAYS. SO ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO WALK THE LENGTH OF THE
PARK BESIDE THE BUILDING CAN DO
SO WITHOUT RUNNING INTO THAT.
THAT FENCE ON BOTH SIDES. I
FEEL THAT IS A GREAT ADDITION.
AND JUST A LINE OF SIGHT THAT
THAT WOULD AFFORD OF THIS VISTA
WITHIN THE PARK. AND. YEAH I
CONSIDER THAT OF. ON THE
FUNDING GENERALLY THAT IS
SOMETHING WE HAVE TO WORK OUT
WITH THE GOVERNOR WE WILL BE IN
A POSITION TO MOVE INTO THE
SPRING SPACE IN OCTOBER OF NEXT
YEAR. THAT WILL ACTUALLY BE
SOMETHING THAT. VIEW THE LANDS
OF THE ANY CONVENTIONS THE
CALIFORNIA A LETTER THE
JASINSKI OF EVERYTHING WE START
MUCKING OUT UP A LITTLE BIT
WHEN WE WERE IN ONE PLACE AND
THEN THE CHAMBERS ARE OVER HERE
WORKING WAITING SESSIONS WE
WILL USE OUR BIG HEARING ROOMS
IN THE NEW BUILDING BUT THEY'LL
BE OTHER HEARING ROOM STILL
OVER HERE PEOPLE BE. SHUTTLING
BACK AND FORTH- PEOPLE WHO COME
TO PARTICIPATE WILL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH METAL DETECTORS
MULTIPLE TIMES IN ORDER TO
VISIT DIFFERENT PLACES AND- YOU
KNOW I TOTALLY AGREE THAT THERE
IS AN ECONOMIC VALUE FROM
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITY FROM
PROJECT ACTIVITY- I THANK AS
THEY DID A HUNDREDS OF YEARS
AGO YOU SORT OF TAKE THE LONG
VIEW. THIS IS SOMETHING THAT- I
BELIEVE WILL INDEED BENEFIT OUR
SYSTEM OF GOVERNMENT. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO WE DIDN'T
HAVE MOTORIZED WHEELCHAIRS IN
THE BILL THEIR PEOPLE WITH.
SERIOUS IMPAIRMENTS. TO BE
ACTIVE PARTICIPANTS THE
GOVERNMENT LIFE IN THE SAME WAY
THEY DO TODAY. AND YET THEY
COME TO THE STATE CAPITOL TODAY
AND THEIR- YOU KNOW. I MAY GO
THIS WAY YOU HAVE TO GO ANOTHER
WAY WE HAVE THESE LIFT WOULD
SEEM A LITTLE PRECARIOUS OF
YOUR WATCH OF. AN OPERATION
IT'S DEFINITELY KINDA LIVING
OUT THE CAPITALS VALUES- TO
WELCOME PEOPLE TO THE BUILDING.
SO I SORT OF FEEL LIKE THE LONG
TERM GOAL IS TO ALIGN THE
CAPITAL WITH THESE. BASIC
VALUES. BUT PART OF IT WAS. HOW
MANY JOBS ARE CREATED PUTS THE
ECONOMIC STIMULUS FOR- FOR THE
REGION. I'M IT'S A IT'S A GREAT
GREAT QUESTION ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE FOUND- BECAUSE
WE DID THE UTAH STATE CAPITOL
DURING THE RECESSION AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT- WE WERE TOLD
IS THAT- CONSTRUCTION TYPICALLY
TURNS A DOLLAR BETWEEN NINE AND
ELEVEN TIMES SO AN AVERAGE OF
ABOUT TEN TIMES WHICH IS ONE OF
THE HIGHEST TURNS WITHIN THE
ECONOMY. SO BY BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION YOU ACTUALLY MOVE
MORE MONEY INTO THE ECONOMY AND
YOU GET MORE PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND IT AND TO
UTILIZE IT THAN YOU DO IN ANY
THEN AND THE OTHER SEGMENTS OF
THE ECONOMY AS I UNDERSTAND IT.
SO I THINK I THINK THAT'S
BENEFICIAL AND THEN JUST TO
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT TREES. ONE
OF THE THINGS WE'RE DOING TO
PROTECT THE TREES IS REMOVING
THE RAPS OUT. INTO THE STREET
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO SO THAT WE- DON'T
HAVE TO TEAR UP THE TREES WITH
WITHIN THE SITE THAT IS. ADDING
A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONEY TO
THE OVERALL BUDGET PART OF
THAT. 710% OVERAGE IS BECAUSE
WE ARE BUILDING THOSE RAMPS.
AND SO WE HAVE TO KIND OF WORK
THROUGH THAT- BUT THE IDEA IS
TO SAVE THOSE. THOSE TREES. IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE ARE WE
BROKE THE TREES INTO THREE
CATEGORIES- THOSE TREES THAT
ARE- HISTORIC. AND PARDON ARE
BEING SAVED OR OR OR MOVED.
WITHIN DEAL WITH THE TREES
THAT- HAVE TO BE REMOVED OR
REPLACED AND THEN WE HAVE THE-
THE PALM TREES AND SO WE'RE
TRYING TO BE VERY CAREFUL AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT EACH GROUP OF
THOSE TREES. SO THAT WE ARE
DOING THE VERY BEST WE CAN TO
MINIMIZE THE DISRUPTION. TO THE
SITE WITH REGARDS TO TREES AND
TO THE DESIGN THAT'S WHY THE
PARKING STRUCTURE WAS MOVED.
FROM THE SOUTH WHERE WE THOUGHT
IT MIGHT GO INITIALLY. TO THE
EAST BECAUSE WE FOUND THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO. REALLY SAVE A
GREAT NUMBER OF TREES. MISTER
HART JUST A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
SINCE YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU
DID THE UTAH CAPITOL DURING A
RECESSION. HOW MUCH LOWER THE
ACTUAL. COST SCHOOL BELOW YOUR-
ESTIMATES RESERVE 10% 20%
SAVINGS BECAUSE- YOU COULD
PRICE THINGS MUCH BETTER SURE-
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. THE
UTAH CAPITOL. WAS HAPPENING
DURING A- AN ECONOMIC RECESSION
DURING THE TIME PERIOD BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND AND TWO AND TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. AND SO IT
WAS LARGELY JUST A SLOWDOWN IN
THE ECONOMY THERE FOR WHAT WE
SAW WE SAW A LOWERING. OF
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES ACROSS
THE STATE WE SAW LOWERING OF
ECONOMIC SPENDING- WHICH IS A
LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN WHAT
WE'RE SEEING TODAY WHICH IS I
THINK THE POINT YOU'RE TRYING
TO GET TO. TODAY THE PROBLEM WE
HAVE IS THAT- THE MATERIALS.
ARE IN SHORT SUPPLY- AND SO. IF
YOU LOOK AT THE LAW OF SUPPLY
AND DEMAND IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN YOUR TYPICAL.
RECESSION ORDER OR OR SLOWDOWN
OF THE ECONOMY BECAUSE WHAT'S
FORCING THAT IS BECAUSE WORKERS
ARE ABLE TO GO AND DO THE WORK
THEY NORMALLY DO AND PRODUCE
THE PRODUCTS THEY TYPICALLY
PRODUCE. RATHER THAN SEEING IT
REDUCING COST WE'RE SEEING SOME
PRODUCTS ACTUALLY RAISING COST.
WE DO THINK THAT OVERALL-
MOVING INTO THIS YEAR AND INTO
NEXT YEAR WE'RE ACTUALLY SEEING
A REDUCTION. OF ESCALATION AND
WE BELIEVE THAT ESCALATION WILL
EITHER BE FLAT OR LOWER OVER
THE NEXT YEAR. BY PERCENT OR TO
THAN WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE
PAST AND WE HAVE AN ECONOMIST
WHO WORKS. FOR US WHO IS
PROJECTING THAT THAT ESCALATION
WILL FLATTEN OUT ACTUALLY DROP.
THERE MAY BE SOME SEGMENTS OF
THE ECONOMY TO GO UP AND SOME
OF THOSE WILL HOLD FLAT SO I
HOPE THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTIONS A LITTLE DIFFERENT
THE TYPICAL RECESSION VERY
GOOD. ASSEMBLY WOMAN COME
LONGER. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I AM ALSO WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THIS VERY COMPREHENSIVE
PRESENTATION- MY QUESTIONS ARE
ALONG THE- LINES OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT JUST SPOKE. YOU
KNOW AS THE STATE IS TIGHTENING.
OUR BUDGET BELT. I DO THINK IT
WOULD BE GOOD AND I KNOW WE
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION AT AN
EARLIER JOINT COMMITTEE HEARING
BUT IT IT MIGHT BE NICE AS A
REFRESHER JUST TO GET AN
ESTIMATED NUMBER OF JOBS- THAT
IT WILL TAKE TO COMPLETE THE
ENTIRE PROJECT BECAUSE AS WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT A RECESSION
AS WE ARE TALKING ABOUT. YOU
KNOW UNEMPLOYMENT- IT WOULD BE
NICE TO HAVE A COUNTER WITH
REAL NUMBERS AS IT RELATES TO
JOBS- THAT WILL BE. CREATED AS
A RESULT OF THIS- AT ENDEAVOR.
I ALSO THINK IT WOULD BE GOOD
TO ALSO HAVE SOME REAL NUMBERS
AROUND THE PAST CONSIDERATIONS
FOR DELAY IN MY PRIOR. LIFE ON
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD WE
WERE DEALING WITH CONSTRUCTION.
I CRY SEVEN CAMPUSES AND EVERY
SMALL THING IN KHURDA CAR. AND
SOMETIMES YOU'RE MAKING
AESTHETIC DECISIONS AND THEN
OTHER TIMES ARE MAKING
BUDGETARY DECISIONS SO. IT
MIGHT BE HELPFUL AT LEAST FOR
ME JUST TO GET A FROM FROM WHAT
THE CAR CONSIDERING WOULD FOR
THE LAKE OF THE VISITORS CENTER.
ABOUT MY HAVE IS THIS FOR
CONTRAST SO ARE THE ANNEXED BY
IS IN SIZE TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCE HEADQUARTERS WERE
BUILDING DOWN THE STREET ON
THAT PARTICULAR PROJECT
REPORTING TO WORK SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED WORKER
MONTHS WHICH MEANS A WORKER
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
WORKERS WORKING FOR A MONTH ON
UP ON THAT PROJECT SO IT'S A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF WORK FOR
WORKERS THAT WERE PUT IN TO
WORK ON A PROJECT LIKE THIS.
THANK YOU. VERY GOOD. V. SO I
MEAN I'VE I'M TO THE THIRTY
DESIGN BUT I THINK AT THE END
OF THE DAY I THINK I'M ALSO
PARTIAL TO THE DESIGN THAT
MIGHT COME IN UNDER BUDGET MOST
QUICKLY AND ALSO TO THE DESIGN
THAT WILL SAVE THE MOST SPACE I
FEEL YOU KNOW AS WE'RE DEALING
WITH. WILDFIRESIT SEEMS LIKE
EVERY DAY HEY OF THE YEAR. I
CAN'T GET ENOUGH. OF THE OXYGEN
THAT COMES FROM TREES AND SO
WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO FACE HAS
MANY OF THEM. I AM FOR. AND
THEN LASTLY I JUST I DIDN'T
WANT TO KNOW. PARDEE DESIGNS
REFEREE TWO OTHER MUNICIPAL
BUILDING BECAUSE I OFTENTIMES
OR SOME SORT OF HISTORICAL
REFERENCE ALL CONNECTION TO THE
DESIGN SO I JUST ADDED NUMBER
THREE I MENTIONED THAT WHEN SHE
WAS IN MEXICO CITY SHE WAS IN A
BUILDING THAT WAS CIRCULAR. AND
SO I JUST I DIDN'T KNOW IF THAT
WAS IN HERE I DIDN'T SEE IT.
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE MY
QUESTION. YES I GENEVA PLEASE
GO AHEAD- IT'S INTERESTING THAT.
IF YOU GO BACK TO SOME OF THE
NATIVE AMERICAN AND SOME OF THE
POLYNESIAN AND SOME OF THE
SOUTH AMERICA SOUTH. PACIFIC
ISLANDER PEOPLE A LOT OF THEIR
CEREMONIAL GATHERINGS WHERE THE
CHIEFS WOULD COME TOGETHER TO
TALK WOULD BE IN A CIRCULAR
BUILDING SO IT'S KIND OF AN
INTERESTING THING I CAN TELL
YOU THAT WE DIDN'T START WITH
THAT IN MIND I THINK THE- THEN
THE NOTION OF A CIRCULAR
BUILDING IF YOU LOOK AT-
THERE'S A BUILDING AND- FRANCE
I BELIEVE THAT IS THE- EUROPEAN
UNION'S HEADQUARTERS A
CIRCULAR- AND THERE'S A NUMBER
OF. OF BUILDINGS ARE CIRCULAR
KIND OF THE NOTES- UNITY AND IT
KIND OF THE NOTES- THAT NO-
EVERYBODY'S KIND OF THE CORE.
WHICH I THINK IS VERY GOOD THAT
THE DOUBLE T. IS REALLY A- A
BUILDING THAT HAS KIND OF
EVOLVED FROM THE NOTION OF HOW
DO WE SAVE. AS MANY TREES AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN SO PULLING THE
CONSTRUCTION AWAY AND THEN
ALLOWING THE FIRST TEE SO TO
SPEAK TO BE SHORTER. AND THE
OTHER ONE TO BE A LITTLE A
LITTLE FURTHER OUT AND THE
SQUARE IS TRYING TO TAKE A
MINIMALISTIC APPROACH. I DON'T
KNOW JOSE IF YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING TO THAT YEAH SURE YEAH
THERE'S ALWAYS A- METAPHOR FOR
A- CONNECTION YOU KNOW FOR
WHAT. WHATEVER THAT MAY MEAN
THAT THE CIRCLE. HE IT IS A
GALLAGHER. LET'S SAY THAT
ANOTHER- YEAH COMMITTEE JUST
BECAUSE OF CONTINUED FOR THE
CLUB AND ALL FIVE RIGHT- EAT
YET WE HAVE ONLY TWO CORNERS
BECAUSE OF THE INCISION WHERE
MAKING TO MAKE THE ENTRY BUT IF
WE DIDN'T DO THAT. EVERY SPACES
SIDE WOULD BE PRETTY EQUAL. AND
IN A SENSE. THAT IS- A BIT OF A
DEMOCRACY MY OPINION- THAT THAT
EVERYONE HAS A VOICE AND
EVERYONE. HAS AN EQUAL SO THAT
THERE'S SOME SORT OF ET
METAPHOR THERE'S THAT THAT ONE
CAN MAKE A CONNECTION EIGHT
ALSO SOME. THAT IN THIS
BUILDING THAT THAT THAT THAT'S
ALL RIGHT IN THE- UNDERNEATH IS.
THE PLAZA IN FRONT THE EARTH
THAN THAT. FIVE FORGET THE NAME
OF THE OTHER BUILDING IS ALSO
SO. A IN THE APT THE WITH A OUT
HAD HELLO THE CIRCULAR EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS NOT COME CIRCLE.
SO THERE IS SOME SORT OF A
PRESS OF FUNDING. IF YOU IF YOU
LOOK AT THE HAS SOME OF THE
ORIGINAL PLAN OF THE PART THEY
WERE AN OLD. IN THE AREA THAT
MUST BE CARRIED IN THE BACK
THAT. IS FELLOW JUST TO BE GIVE
PRESS PREFERENCE TO THAT TO THE
THAT EAST WEST AXIS WHICH IS AB.
IN THE SORT OF PERSPECTIVE. SO
THERE ARE SOME PRESS FOR THAT.
THAT WILL BE A THE RED.
BUILDINGS ARE VERY WELL AS HERE
THIS BILL IS I MAY CUTTING. OF
THAT SO THAT NOTHING WRONG WITH
THE OTHER AS WELL SO THAT THAT
SORT OF MY PERSPECTIVE. I WANT
TO ASK A THE SMALL THE BEFORE I
GO TO THE GAL. PHONE OPERATOR
IS SENATOR BOB HERTZBERG ON THE
LINE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NOT TO MY KNOWLEDGE. IS IT
CENTERS SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
ONLINE YOU MAY PRESS STAR THEN
ZERO. WELL WE'RE DOING ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
GENERALS COMMITTEE ON THE FLOOR.
FOR MATHIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THINK WE FOR A LOT OF COMMENTS
I THINK A LOT OF US BORROWED
INGREDIENTS I THINK MY BIGGEST
QUESTION RIGHT NOW AND I. IS
IT- IT'S UNFORTUNATELY- THAT WE
DO NOT HAVE QUORUM TODAY
BECAUSE I THINK A LOT OF US
WOULD WANT TO VOTE TO MOVE
FORWARD- JUST IN THE FACT THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT IF. WE CAN SAY
LET'S MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
SQUARE THE CIRCLE LEARN THE
DOUBLE T. DAN. OUR FOLKS THAT
ARE DOING ALL OF THIS GREAT
WORK THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM
TODAY THEN THEY'RE NOT SPENDING
EXTRA TIME AND MONEY. LOOKING
AT THESE OTHER OPTIONS. I WISH
THAT WE COULD SAY HEY LET'S
TAKE THE DOUBLE T. OFF THE
TABLE OR YOU KNOW LET'S FIND TO
DATE BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE DON'T
HAVE A CAR I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S AN ADMINISTRATIVE
MEASURE ON THAT CAN BE DONE
THROUGH THE AUTHORITY- OF THE
CHAIRS. BLUT A THINK THAT IF WE
GET. KIND OF BRING IT DOWN- WE
WOULD ALSO SEE A LOT OF MONEY
INCOME A LOT OF TIME ON FOR
THOSE WHO ARE GOING THROUGH
THIS PLANNING PROCESS SIX
SPECIALLY AS AS MENTIONED
EARLIER BY OUR COLLEAGUES- WITH
THE RECESSION WITH EVERYTHING
ELSE FOR EVERYBODY VERY.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE STATE
SPENDING ADDITIONAL FONTS A
DEFINING UNFORTUNATELY THAT WE
DO NOT HAVE MEMBERS HERE-
PERSONALLY AFTER LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING AFTER LOOKING AT ALL
THE NUMBERS AFTER LOOKING AT
THE ECOLOGICAL REPORTS ON YOU
KNOW HOW WE SEE THE MOST TREES.
HOW DO WE SAVE THE MOST MONEY-
SECURITY PUBLIC SPACE
EVERYTHING- I THINK THE BEST
THIS. MODEL FOR US TO GO
FORWARD WITH WOULD BE THE
CIRCLE. I DO APPRECIATE THE
HISTORY LESSON ON ON WITH THE.
WHERE THE CIRCLE CAME FROM MY
IT REMINDS ME OF- MY OLD ART
HISTORY CLASSES BUT- WE LIKE
TAMARA GRECO ROMAN AND
COLISEUM'S IN THOSE THINGS-
GOING BACK AND SOME OF YOU IN
THE GOTHIC DESIGN. VOIGTS I
THINK THE MEANING BEHIND THAT
ALSO CARRIES A LOT OF WEIGHT.
BUT THE ACCESSIBILITY FOR THE
PUBLIC THE PUBLIC SPACE- THE
ABILITY FOR THEM TO SEE THE
DOWN ON THE TICKET AND THE BILL
TO HAVE THAT GALLERY TO
SHOWCASE- ALL THE DIFFERENT
AREAS OF CALIFORNIA. IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AS WELL BUT-
AGAIN THE QUESTION IS MORE OF.
IF WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE
AN ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION WHICH
IS USUALLY SOMETHING I'M NOT IN
FAVOR OF- TO CUT SOME TIME AND
MONEY SO. OUR DESIGN TEAM ISN'T
SPINNING THEIR WHEELS ON
SOMETHING MOST OF US ARE IN
AGREEMENT WITH YEAH I
ANTICIPATE THAT WHILE. I DO SEE
THAT. SCHEDULE A JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE MEETING BEFORE THE
END OF THE MONTH. AND BRING UP
FOR FOUR DECISION. AND I THINK
OF. OUR DESIGN TEAM I HAVE TO
SAY IS AN EXCEPTIONAL JOB TO
CONJURE UP THREE FAIRLY
CONCRETE ALTERNATIVES TO BRING
IT TO THIS BODY. I ASKED THEM
TO DO THAT I DIDN'T FEEL AS MY
PROGRESS TO MAKE A CHOICE I
FEEL THE LAW GIVES J. R. C.
PREEMINENT. RESPONSIBILITY TO
MAKE THAT DECISION. AND BUT I
THINK THEY HAVE HEARD LOUD AND
CLEAR. COMMENTARY TODAY WHICH
WILL HELP THEM START FOCUSING.
BUT EVERYTHING MUST BE DONE IN
A PROPER MANNER. AND WE'RE WE
ARE NOT DONE WE HAVE PURSES
HERE TO COMMENT ON FRIDAY YOUR
POINTS ARE VERY WELL MADE TIME
IS OF THE ESSENCE AND- WE DID
NOT HAVE ALL THIS MATERIAL
TOGETHER FIVE AND A HALF MONTHS
AGO BUT WE HAD A TOWARD RULES
MEETING. TO START GIVING MORE
DIRECTION AND MARCH. AND IT'S
STILL ON THE WEBSITE IT WAS
CANCELED. AND OF COURSE THEN
THE YEAR TOOK THE COURSE IT
TOOK. AND SO WE ARE NOW BACK ON
TASK AND MOVING FORWARD- SO WE
WILL MOVE WITH ALACRITY- A
SIMILAR MATHIS. AND TURNING NOW
TO. WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBERS
WITH US. I WOULD JUST ASK YOU
TO. IDENTIFY YOURSELF AND I'M
GOING TO ASK FOR TWO MINUTES OF
COMMENTS BUT PLEASE JUMP IN
THIS PROJECT OUR- THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN COOLEY A RICHER CAL
ONE WITH PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR OUR CAPITAL. I SEE THE
DESIGN FOR THE VISITOR CENTER
WE'RE SEEING TODAY OR TONIGHT
FOR THE FIRST TIME IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN THAT WAS IN THE
RECIRCULATED DRAFT E. IR. I
JUST NOTE THAT- THE NEW PARKING
LOCATION THE STRIP ALONG
TWELFTH STREET IS ABSOLUTELY
NOT IN THE PREVIOUS E. I. R. IF
WE TRUST THE ARBORIST THAT
ANYTHING FIFTY FEET FROM AN
EXCAVATION. WOULD PUT IT RISK
AT. I AM CONCERNED THAT THAT
THE PARKING GARAGE LOCATION
WOULD IMPINGE WITHIN FIFTY FEET
OF THE CIVIL WAR GROWTH AND I
KNOW THAT'S VERY PERSONALLY
VERY IMPORTANT TO YOU- SO IT
CAUTIONED THERE IT APPEARS THE
DOUBLE T. SCHEME VIOLATES WHAT
IN THE ARE WAS A PRIEST THE I.
R. WAS A PRECEPT. WE WOULD NOT
GO BEYOND THE NORTH AND SOUTH
BOUNDARIES OF THE HISTORIC
CAPITAL. THE CIRCLE SEEMS SEEMS
SCHEME SEEMS TO DO THAT ALSO-
AND IT ALSO PROTRUDES INTO THE
TWELFTH ST ALIGNMENT WHICH WAS
PRESERVED IN THE E. I. R. IT
SEEMS ALL THREE SCHEMES GO
ABOVE THE PARAPET. OF THE-
RESTORED CAPITAL AGAIN A
PRECEPT I THOUGHT WE HAD
PRESERVED IN THE- E. IR N. FOR
A PROJECT THAT WAS BASED ON ON
GOSH WE REALLY NEED MORE SPACE-
THE VERY VERY LARGE GALLERIES.
TAKING UP A LOT OF SQUARE FEET
IN MULTIPLE FLOORS- SEEM LIKE
THEY WOULD BE SOMETHING KIND OF
HARD TO EXPLAIN. AND FINALLY AS
A FORMER CONTRACTOR I KNOW THE
BLUE BOOK ESTIMATE ON THE
VISITORS CENTER WAS TWENTY NINE
MILLION AND IT DIDN'T SAY IT
DID NOT INCLUDE THE SOFT COSTS
AS SO FROM TWENTY NINE UP TO
WHAT ARE WE SEVENTY EIGHT. HE
PRETTY BIG JOB THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY VERY MUCH FOR CALLING.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
PUBLIC GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK
I SEE THERE IS NONE. SO WE WILL
NOW GO TO THE PHONELINES- I DO
THANK YOU MISTER COUNT FOR
COMING TODAY. I WILL SAY YOUR
MATERIALS HAVE BEEN DISTRIBUTED
TO ALL THE MEMBERS. M.
MODERATOR PLEASE REMIND CALLERS
HOW TO OPEN THEIR LINES AND
LIKE LET'S TAKE IN THE COLORS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THE CURRENT AGENDA YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE AGAIN YOU'LL HEAR A
TONE INDICATING THAT HEARING Q.
AND IF YOU AREN'T YOU AT THIS
TIME PLEASE CONFIRM THAT YOU.
ARE IN SUPPORT WHAT INFORMATION
MR TERRIBLE TO THE FIRST LINE.
LINE TWENTY NINE TO NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
KATE RILEY AND NOT SPEAKING IN
IN SUPPORT HOWEVER. THANK YOU
ALL HOPE YOU RE QUEUE THEN.
LINE THIRTY FIVE THREE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM NOT
SUPPORT WEEK YOU MAKE YOU. LINE
FIFTY THREE FIVE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS JEROME
I'M NOT IN SUPPORT PLEASE READ
TO ME. THANK YOU. PINE FIFTY
SIX FIVE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M NOT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN IF ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE ISN'T SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NONBINDING QUEUE AT THIS
TIME WE- WE'RE ASKING THEM TO
KEEP THEIR COMMENTS AS I DID IN
THE GALLERY TO TWO MINUTES WHY
DON'T WE MOVE ON TO THE
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING. AND AGAIN THE-
PRESENTATION IS AVAILABLE ON
THE- ASSEMBLY WEBSITE ANNEXED
ON ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV. AND
I TURN OVER THE MODERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOUR POSITION IS
IN OPPOSITION OF WHAT HAS BEEN
PRESENTED YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. BEGIN
YOU SHOULD HEAR A TONE
INDICATING THAT YOUR IN Q.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE TWENTY
NINE TO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME'S KATE RILEY.
CAPITAL THE CAPITAL ANNEX RIGHT
NOW IT'S A GHOST TOWN NEAR THE
EMPTY BEFORE YOU GIVE A GREEN
LIGHT TO A BILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT THAT WILL BE PAID BACK
BY YOUR CONSTITUENTS OVER THE
NEXT TWENTY FIVE YEARS THINK
ABOUT THIS HOW MANY OF THE
STAFF PEOPLE. REALLY NEED TO
COME BACK HOW MANY COULD
CONTINUE TO WORK ON A MODIFIED
REMOTE SCHEDULE. THAT'S THE
QUESTION THAT THE REST OF STATE
GOVERNMENT IS ASKING ITSELF
RIGHT NOW THE GOVERNOR CALLED
COURT IS MAY REVISED WHEN HE
PUT DEBATE ON ROADS AND NATURAL
RESOURCES BUILDING PROJECTS ON
PAUSE. PENDING A STATEWIDE
EVALUATION OF OFFICE SPACE
NEEDS. INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT
REDUCED OPERATE NEEDS TO THE
REMOTE WORKING OR THE LESS
COSTLY OPTION A RENOVATION OF
THE HISTORIC STATE CAPITAL. THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE HAS DONE
THE OPPOSITE TODAY PROVIDING A
BIGGER FIGHT TWEETED OPTIONS
THAT IS SHOCKINGLY DIFFERENT
FROM THAT PROPOSED BY THE
REVISED DVR. THE THREE OPTIONS
LOOK LIKE DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF
A WORRISOME APPROACH
UNDERSTATEMENT ORIGINAL CAPITOL
BUILDING WHICH MEMBERS OF THE
JOINT RULES YOU CAN'T SAY NO
THINK OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS THE
LOST JOBS THE PERILOUS FINANCES
THE ILLNESS AND DEATHS AND
FAMILIES TORN APART BY THREATEN
DISRUPTION. TO CLOSE BUSINESSES
AND CHALLENGING SCHOOL ON
HEALTHCARE CRISES IF YOU TELL
ME CONSTITUENTS YOU'RE VOTING
TO SUPPORT OF BILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT FOR YOUR OPPOSITE THAT
THEY'LL BE PAYING FOR LIKE
ABOUT CREDIT CARD FOR THE NEXT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. YOU THINK
THEY WILL AGREE THIS IS A WISE
CHOICE THANK YOU FOR LISTENING
TO MY COMMENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT CALLER. LINE SIXTY
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
SORRY LINE SIXTEEN SIX ZERO
WHAT IS YOUR TELEPHONE ON MUTE.
HI LINE SIX ZERO LINE IS OPEN.
WE'LL GO TO LINE FIFTY SIX FIVE
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS MERION MILLEN. MORNING
I THOUGHT MY FRONT PORCH
COVERED IN ASH AND DUST FROM
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE DEVASTATION
AND A DUST STORM FROM THE
PACIFIC NORTHWEST DUE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE UNDERSTATE BOX
DOWN FOR SIX MONTHS CITIZENS
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS STUDENTS
WHO OWNS AND LOVED ONES.
SOMETHING THROUGH INSIDE
FAMILIES ARE PREVENTED FROM
BEING WITH OLDER THE NEED EVEN
AFTER BEDS AND FUNERALS PEOPLE
ARE MARCHING IN THE STREETS
PROTESTING THE LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY OF CIVIC LEADERS
AND LAWMAKERS. THE CAPITOL
ANNEX PROJECT. AS PROPOSED. IT
MEANS. OUR GROUND AND THINK
THAT SHE HAD MADE A COMMUNITIES
RESOURCE WHICH WOULD ACT THE
PARK THIRTY. THESE ARE LIFE AND
DEATH IS THE IS NOT A RISK OR A
SMALL. THE JOINT COMMITTEE THE
PRICE IS TRANSIT BUT IT THANK
AND SHE WITHHOLDING DR AND NON.
AGREEMENT. WHY TODAY IS THE DAY
RULES AND THEIR INTENTION
KEEPER. WITH BUILDING A LUXURY
HIGH TECH FACILITIES AND MAKE
PEOPLE CAL CAPE THEM WITH ENTRY.
INSTEAD OF WHICH SHE GAMES THE
ENTIRE CAN COULD BE. A PART OF
THE CAP AND IT FOR ME OF OCT.
ADDRESSING POST CO WOULD BE
ALLERGIES. SEVEN NEWSOM CALLED
FOR PART OF THE STATE OF
BUILDING. FOR STAY ONE L. AND
BY REVIEW. SHE BILL EIGHT
THIRTY BECAUSE NUMBER TO CAN
DEMO AND CONSTRUCTION OF THESE.
FOR REGISTER BE ABILITY AND
RENOVATION OR- OF THE ANNEX.
ALTERNATIVES TO DEMOLITION WERE
NEVER STUDIED. SIGNIFICAN
CHANGES THE PROJECT TODAY A
REEALING TODAY'S PRISON.
WARRANT AND RESEARCH DRAFT
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REVIEW. AS
OF NOW THE FOR THOUSAND SIGNED
AN ONLINE PETITION BECAUSE
CAPITOL ANNEX. THEY WHO DO YOU
FOR IF YOU WORK FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA YOU WILL ALSO
CALL FOR PARKS OF THE PROJECT
PROCEED WITH CONSIDERATION OF
THE UNPRECEDENTED REALITIES WE
ALL NOW FACE TIME YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. NINE THIRTY
THREE THREE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PARTY ONLINE THIRTY
THREE. YOU MAY GO AHEAD. WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO HEAR YOU AT THIS
TIME HOME OF ON LINE FIFTY
THREE FIVE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE GERMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GOOD AFTERNOON
DRAWING TICKETS HERE FOR THE
NIGHT OF AUBURN INDIAN
COMMUNITY. ON BEHALF OF THE
NIGHT ALL THEY NEED TO TRAVEL
COUNCIL. WE SUPPORT THE IDEA OF
REDESIGN IN RESPONSE TO THE
PRESENCE OF RESORT. HOWEVER
GIVEN THE CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE
AND TAKEN IT TO THE CAPITOL
GROUNDS JERRY TRIBES. UNITED
AUBURN IS DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT
THIS LAST ROUND TO REDESIGN.
WHICH IS ONLY PROVIDED TO LOOK
JUST LAST NIGHT. DO NOT ALLOW
FOR ME FULL REVIEW OF THE
CONCEPT DESIGNS BY THE IMPACT
THE TRIBES. FOR COMPLETION OF
TROPICAL FOR RESOURCE SITE
INVESTIGATIONS AS OUTLINED
BILLION AT AUBURN'S MEDIATION
AGREEMENT. WITH THE U. S. WE DO
A- ALL THE- FOCUSED ON THE TREE
AND APPLE PARK DURING THE
PRESENT. WE DISMAYED AND IS. W.
HEARD ABSENT NOTHING. ABOUT
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE TRIBE
HISTORICALLY OCCUPIED THIS AREA.
UNITED ALREADY HAD TO FIX. ON
PROJECT IN THE DIRECTION BOB
IT'S BEEN GOING FOR OVER A YEAR
NOW. WE WERE PROMISED THAT THIS
PROJECT WILL BE THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR THE SPECTACLE
STATION THIRTY TRIBES THAT
CLEARLY DOES NOT TRUE.
RESPECTFULLY APPLICATION DID
NOT ON ANY DESIGN ELEMENTS.
BIGELOW REQUIRED IN GOVERNMENT
GOVERNMENT TO PROCESS OCCURS.
THIS IS NOT YET HAPPENED. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. LINE
SEVENTY ONE SEVEN ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
BILLY FUNDERBURK I AM A MEMBER
OF THREE FIFTY SACRAMENTO AND
HEARD OF A COUPLE. ANNEX GROUP
THAT WHAT CAN HAVE A BETTER I
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TODAY WHO HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS REGARDING. THE
TREE AT THE CAPITOL PARK AS
WELL AS THE COST OF THE PROJECT
TO TAXPAYERS. BUT I WOULD- ECHO
THE CONCERNS- OF SHARON AND
TINA COULD JUST SPOKE. ABOUT
THE LACK OF CONSULTATION WITH
NATIVE COMMUNITIES BECAUSE
CENTERING THE PRESERVATION OF
THE URBAN GREEN SPACE. WITH
CONSULTATION OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ABSOLUTELY PARAMOUNT. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK. THE TEAM
FOR. WE NEED TO IN THE PARKING
LOT THE UNDERGRAD PARKING SO
THAT DOES HOW. MUCH SMALLER IN
ON THE DREAMLAND WITH CAPITAL.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT THAT
PARTICULAR DESIGN AND BE
TREATED IT IT APPEARS THAT THE
DESIGN GOES AROUND THAT WOULD
HELP THE ATHLETES COMMITTEE TO
CLARIFY THE INTENTION IS BUILT
AROUND LARGE TREES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN THE FOOT PRINT OF
THAT. NEW PARKING DESIGN. BUT
IT WITH THE PARKING LOT AND PUT
GIVEN THE VEHICLE AND ENTRANCE
A THE LARGE CONTRIBUTION FOR
GREENHOUSE EMISSIONS AND THAT'S-
I THINK IT WOULD SHAMEFUL FOR
THE FLIGHT TO DEVELOPED AND UP
PARK LOT AT THE- OF CAPITAL
PARK IS THE TOP TRIAL. AND I
WOULD URGE THE COMMITTEE TO DO
ALL IT CAN WITH ENOUGH POWER TO
PRESERVE AND PROTECT THE TREES
AND ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROCESS AND
PROVIDING FEEDBACK AND TO THAT
END I WOULD ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE ASKED WE CALCULATED
DRAFT ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
REVIEW GIVEN THE SUBSTANTIAL
CHANGE. AFFECTED BY PREVENT. SO
THAT THE PUBLIC CAN COMMENT ON
THE CURRENT DEFINE PROVIDED
THEM. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE LINE. THANK
YOU MISTER LINE THIRTY FIVE
THREE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS CALLED. WE THE
PUBLIC ARE BEING RAILROADED
HE'S CLEARLY MADE A CHOICE BUT
YOU'VE NEVER TRULY SHARED WITH
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATING FOR
BILLS FOR THIS PROJECT THEY
KNEW NOTHING ABOUT. WHAT YOU
SWORE WITH THE IRS HOLDING THIS
MEETING DURING YOUR RECESS WITH
VERY LITTLE NOTICE TO THE MEDIA
OR THE PUBLIC IS TYPICAL OF
THIS ENTIRE PROJECT OCCURRED
YOU MISTER COOLEY FOCUSED ON
KEEPING THE PUBLIC MOSTLY IN
THE DARK NOR DOES THE ANNEX
WEBSITE PROVIDE THE DETAIL THE
PUBLIC DESERVES PUBLIC SHOULD
BE ABLE TO DOWNLOAD THE ENTIRE
PROJECT OAKLAND YOU WOULD SHE
CONSIDER PORT AND RESOLUTIONS
WE CAN ACTUALLY READ. THE COST
SPREADSHEET SHOWN THE ENTIRE
PROJECT INTO WHATEVER YOU WANT
TO TODAY THE ANNEX WEBSITE IT'S
A SHAME WHAT FOCUS CHOI BUT
NEVER HAD STATE. FOR YOU ALL
CHOSE TO RESTORED BUILDING AND
TEAR UP THE PAR IT SURE WAS
MISSED COOLEY TO EACH SAVE INTO
OUT. FIVE OPTION ON HOW NOT ONE
CREW ABOUT ACTUAL LANDSCAPE
PLAN WILL NOT ONE OF THE WOULD
CARE ENOUGH ABOUT THE END
PRODUCT OF ONE IT ADEQUATELY.
ALONE HE. EIGHT THIRTY SIX TO
RESTORING ABILITY ONE OF THE TO
RECONSTRUCT THE STATE CAPITOL
ANNEX. WHAT ARE THE DOCUMENTS
COMPARING COSTS. ON THOSE
OPTIONS AND NOW WITH A FIFTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
DEFICIT YOU'RE STILL AHEAD
YOU'RE FREE. FREE UNDER BROWN
PARKING LOT. AND A VISITOR
EVENT CENTER AT A COST OF ONE
DOLLARS WITH INTEREST. ONLY
REVENUE BOND. WHAT BILLION AS A
PRIVILEGE TO DO OF US STRUCTURE
FROM MORE OF OUR JOBS
BUSINESSES. REPOR I AM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS. NEXT CALL.
THERE ARE COMMENT IN THE PRESS
ONE BUTTON WILL GO TO LINE
TWENTY TWO TWO TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MANY AND THANK NINE I'M A
RESIDENT OF THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO. ON FRIDAY. THE
LITTLE ARBOR. I BEEN VERY IN
THE FOLLOWING FOR THE SAKE THE
TREE. BUT I'D LIKE TO DO THIS I
THINK THERE ISSUE AT HAND IN
MANY OF THE SPEAKERS HAVE
TOUCHED ON THEM THE CLOAK OF
SECRECY. THE IS PLAN WITH ONLY
RELEASED NIGHT. OF OCT TO
REVIEW. THAT THE GOVERNOR
CALLED. BUILDINGS ARE FOR
SPATIAL. AND THEN THE THAT
THERE'S YOU IN THE CAR LOT
BEING BUILT. FOR YEAH WHAT YOU
FROM AT THIS FIFTY THE WRONG.
PINE SERVICE PRO IT NEEDS
PUBLICLY QUITE FRANKLY I BEEN
I'VE I'VE HUNTED FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY GIVE PUBLICLY GUILT
AND HOW NOT IT I DON'T KNOW
WHERE THE CONTRACTORS BEEN
DOING THEIR CONCEPT THE VERY
DIFFICULT. THIRTY ABOUT THIS.
THE PRIOR FEW I URGE. THE
GOVERNING BODY TO TAKE A BIT OF
LOOK AT THEIR- IF BACK AND TO
HOLD FROM ANY ACTIVE WITHIN IT
IS THE TIME TO CALL. AT TIME TO
AT THE BUDGET AND I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE TIME TO.
SHARE MY THOUGHTS THANK YOU
MA'AM. THAT'S CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER NO OTHER CO
AND AT THIS. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE AMERICAN THIS
WILL CONCLUDE HERE AND I THANK
ALL THE MEMBERS FOR
PARTICIPATING IT IS ANTICIPATED
THAT WE WILL BE CONVENE IN A
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE MEETING
BY THE END OF THE MONTH. TO
BRING THESE QUESTIONS BACK FOR
THE FULL MEMBERSHIP. ADDED IS
OF I JUST THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING THERE HAS BEEN.
AS I SAID AT THE OUTSET THIS
ACTUALLY STE CONVERSATION
STARTER UNDER GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER IT CONTINUED
UNDER GOVERNOR BROWN HE SIGNED
AUTHORIZING LEGISLATION- IT HAS
BEEN. AVAILABLE ONLINE AND A
SERVER FOR FREQUENT COMMENTARY
SOCIAL MEDIA FOR THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS- THERE'S A GREAT
DEAL GOING ON IN CALIFORNIA I
CANNOT ACCOUNT FOR PEOPLE THAT
REALLY DO ALWAYS LOOK AT THE
WEBSITE BUT IT'S BEEN. VERY
VERY PUBLIC ON A CONTINUAL
BASIS I THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING I THINK FOR THE
PROVISION OF ALL THIS
INFORMATION HERE TODAY- CENTER
MONEY DO YOU HAVE ANY
CONCLUDING REMARKS YOU WISH TO
MAKE. ALL RIGHT WITH THAT THIS
MINISTER. THANK YOU.